Could even hear their breathing.
It's a sensitive.
Yeah.
It's good stuff.
Lab already.
Damn.
There's no countdown.
Jamie.
You're radical.
Radical.
Mr Goes in.
Go back to be here.
Thanks Mr Lindsay.
Good to James or Jim depending upon
preferences.
That's right.
Go with Jim a jet.
First of all gentlemen.
And there was one other person that you
did this with.
This whole project.
Helen pluck rose from England.
A shout out to Helen from England.
She back across the pond,
right?
He's across the pond.
Fish and chips and she's making tea and
managerial magazine.
That's great.
Excellent.
Alright,
well shout out to her as well.
Um,
let's explain what you guys did and
what's so significant about it because
when I first read it,
my first inclination that I had two
reactions.
One was a huge laugh.
I laughed really hard and then I said
thank God so many exposed this.
Yup.
So tell me,
tell me what you guys do over.
Let's explain who you guys are,
what you do.
Okay.
Um,
my background is in mathematics.
I bailed out an academia in 2010 though
because I kind of see the writing on the
wall and uh,
so now I am a renegade gender scholar
and I write nonsense about genitals.
That's primarily what I do.
I mean,
I manage a business at home,
so I got to academia.
Yeah.
And I'm uh,
uh,
I teach philosophy of Portland State
University and uh,
met Jim years ago,
we collaborated and we've written a
number of things over the years and at
some point it just came to the,
we had to do something about this.
It was just too ridiculous and it was
translating into the real world.
And so we collaborated and here we are.
Well,
let's explain what you did and what was
ridiculous.
Um,
what we're talking about,
what was ridiculous is there's many
fields of studies,
um,
that you can get legitimate degrees in
that are absolutely preposterous,
right?
Literally filled with nonsense,
taught by nonsense.
People who live in these nonsense
bubbles,
right?
And then they give these degrees and
these people go out in the real world
and they infect things.
They in their,
their ridiculousness infect certain,
particularly tech industry businesses
like you see it in King James.
Yeah.
Well it's explained what you guys did.
Yeah,
so we started about a year,
I guess a year and a half ago now is
last summer.
We started writing a bunch of academic
papers for the journals that represent
these fields and so everybody
understands what an academic paper is
getting out of the gate.
This isn't like an op Ed that you dash
off or like Washington Post or some
magazine or whatever.
This is a thing like academics work
their careers to write one or two of
these a year.
And so they're really hard to write.
They're supposed to be hard to get
published.
So we were up 20 of them in 10 months
and uh,
seven of those got accepted for,
were actually published.
And um,
then we got lost for more.
Yeah,
we got busted and at least four more.
We're on track.
Maybe five or six more would've gotten
in.
What's the difference between getting
accepted and getting published?
So the process with everything in
academia is really slow and a lot of
people don't know this,
so you send off this article,
the editor looks at it and the editor
either gives it the thumbs up or the
thumbs down.
If they give it the thumbs up,
it goes off to peer reviewers and that
process takes months often as long as I
mean would one paper that was eight
months under peer review.
So the reviewers look at it,
they try to figure out if the arguments
are good,
they try to figure out if the research
is good,
they evaluate that,
they give extensive comments,
they send it back to you,
then you have to revise it according to
whatever they say.
Make it better is what's supposed to
happen.
They made ours crazier and so then they
did.
Every single time
we took the feedback and made the papers
just the most extreme,
most extreme things and so then you send
them back.
So now you're probably three,
four months in just the review process,
not to the writing,
which should also take months.
And then the editor will either send it
back to the reviewers to see if it was
good enough or they'll just evaluated
themselves depending on where it stands
and then they'll make a decision as to
whether or not to accept it or reject it
or ask for more revisions.
And then when they accept it,
that means the is ready to publish it.
But then the publishing process requires
all the typesetting,
proofing,
all the stuff that goes into making it
professional for an academic journal.
And that can take months
and,
and publishing is the coin of the realm
like fats it.
So the ideal is one paper every year in
the humanities probably.
So if you,
that's how you credential yourself.
That's how you get tenure,
which is a job for life.
That's how you get to teach people these
ideas who then,
as you said,
go out into the workforce,
you know,
five,
six years later.
And in fact everybody with total
silliness.
So the,
it's the gold standard peer review.
So we saw a tremendous problem.
Can we tell people some of the titles of
these charter?
Because right now they're like,
what the hell are these guys talking?
So we had a article,
the one that got the most press was
about dog humping and Portland,
Oregon.
It was called.
How did it go?
Was it called um,
queer performativity and uh,
was it rape culture,
rape culture?
We're performativity in dog parks in
Portland or.
Yeah,
we claim to have examined under a fake
name is formativity.
Oh yeah,
totally.
Have their own lingo.
Their own,
you know.
But is that a word in the English
language before
activity?
I mean in the academic English language.
Not In common parlance,
but that's like the whole thing.
This is huge,
right?
This goes back a long way.
That's Judith Butler.
His whole thing was that gender
different?
Butler.
Judith Butler is probably the most
influential feminist scholar there.
Gender scholar I should say,
that that's been in maybe the last 30
years.
She's,
she's big time.
And so she had this whole thing that
gender is performative.
It's something you perform.
It's not something that has anything to
do with your biology treated article.
Reactions to rape culture in Queer
performativity at urban dog parks in
Portland,
Oregon.
Why is it retracted?
Because it's because I realized bogus.
We're hosing them,
we reactions to rape culture and queer
performance.
We claim to have closely examined the
genitals of just under 10,000,
210,000
dogs and then interrogated their owners
as to their sexual orientation.
So we checked out the dog's nuts and
then said,
excuse me sir,
are you gay?
And if they gendered their dogs,
well we made up these totally insane,
you know,
dogs humping incidents and how they,
they beat female dogs but they didn't
beat male dogs.
So that's one of the papers that we
made,
you know the other paper that will,
will this one also,
they had the whole thing like if a male
dog humps another male dog,
especially men would freak out and break
it up.
Stop that because that's the queer
performativity part.
But then if a male dog humped a female
dog,
they'd be like,
you know,
get her girl.
Get her,
get her,
you know,
get on it.
You're basically raging against Hetero
normativity.
Exactly correct.
We told them exactly what they wanted to
hear and we gave them bogus statistics
to fuel what they already wanted to
believe.
Yeah.
We started off with the idea that what
we wanted to get to as a conclusion and
then we made up all the crap in between
to get to it and the conclusion was
feminism should train men the way we
train dogs so that we can get rid of
rape culture.
They'll put them on leashes,
you know,
it's right in the paper.
It's all there.
Unfortunately we cannot put them in
Aleisha.
It's not politically feasible to put men
on leashes.
You guys wrote that.
He had told their leashes when they
misbehave in this paper,
didn't just get published.
The Journal said that this was exemplary
scholarship and gave it an award.
So it was one of the best pieces.
This year is their 25th anniversary.
So this journal's has been doing this
for 25 years and it's their 25th
anniversary.
So they're picking out the best papers.
So pull year and putting them,
you know,
pride of place in some,
some issue of the journal and ours was
going to be in the seventh issue was so
number one is greater,
it's not great.
So it either is greater,
it's not great like why they retracting
it because they know we were bogus.
So what?
Like a broken clock.
The clock is broken,
what it is actually 12:00.
So they would claim it's incorrectly
that we fabricated statistics but we,
we wrote other paper's called one was
fat bodybuilding,
so that claim that there should be a
category introducing traditional body
building called fat body bodybuilding
where people come and display their fat
before the audience and we didn't
manufacturing and statistics for that
and they love that.
They thought it.
You know,
one line in that paper was a fat body is
a built body of the reviewers.
Like I wholeheartedly agree.
Something like that.
Yeah.
And then we wrote other papers like to
Hypatia we published a paper,
got accepted,
not published,
but that one we claim that it's
unacceptable.
It's honestly,
it's unethical to make fun of anything
to do with social justice.
Right?
And so if you want to make fun of things
that don't have anything with social
justice,
that's good.
So if we wanted to make fun of men,
that's great.
If you want to make fun of white people,
If you want to make fun of anything to
do with social justice,
that's a problem.
So we made was.
We said that South Park is a huge
problem.
The simpsons is a huge problem.
We went into talking about how Stephen
Colbert and Jon Stewart have the right
idea,
but then the journal was like,
oh,
but they're straight white male.
So you have to nuance around that to
make it clear that their position is
white men even though they're on the
side of social justice,
it's not quite good enough,
you know.
So they publish that.
They published that,
they published that.
Was that.
What was that one called?
That one was called when the joke's on
you and we made.
We wrote it.
They would think the joke is on us
because we cited our own work in there,
but the joke was actually on them for
publishing it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's so.
It's so funny how racist you can be as
long as you're racist against white
people.
That's what we saw is that as long as
you are going up the river against
privileged,
then you can really just get away with
some.
And you could generalize.
Oh,
totally gross generalizations.
It's not treat people as individuals.
Absolutely.
It's very strange.
It's very strange that this is the left,
you know,
I was a kid in San Francisco in the 19
seventies.
Uh,
we lived in,
you know,
like was the hippie times and that's,
I,
I lived there from age seven to 11 and
it kind of formed a lot of my opinions
about people like that who gives a shit.
Part of my,
my,
my appreciation for any group,
whatever it is,
whether it's race or gender or sexual
orientation and I just,
I don't understand it from either way.
I certainly don't understand it from a
racist perspective,
but I really don't understand it from
racism that's condoned because it's
racism against white people.
This is the left,
this is the.
These are,
these are the people that are preaching
against hate and these are the people
that used to be the people that were
supposedly so open minded and so open to
ideas and now they're trying to stifle
creativity and stifled dissent and
stifle,
stifle anything that doesn't fit inside
that very narrow paradigm they're trying
to push.
It's very strange.
No,
they co opted the civil rights movement.
The good name of the civil rights
movement is kind of the brand they ride
on.
You know,
they're fighting against racism.
They're fighting against sexism,
misogyny,
et Cetera,
and the thing is,
is that's not really what's going on
here.
They've actually tapped into this to,
to throw around the term,
this postmodern notion that everything
in society has to do with power dynamics
and the power dynamics have to be
understood in terms of groups and how
those groups have traditionally held
power and exercise power.
And so immediately it becomes stuck in
this idea that it's all about this group
or that group and how they relate to one
another.
And I don't mean like,
Hey,
let's get along relate.
I mean like white people are imagined to
always be over black people and
therefore,
you know,
there's always as natural power dynamic
of,
of oppressor versus oppressed.
And this is stuff that came straight out
of this weird postmodern philosophy
where you said he's dissatisfied French
philosophers in the sixties,
you know,
all one,
this is,
all this stuff you were talking about
was going down.
Um,
they saw this stuff and they said,
wow,
you know,
okay,
power dynamics or the thing,
because I should go back a step.
The postmodern philosophers like food co
and all of this got all hooked up on
power because they were too satisfied
with seeing what they called grand
narratives.
Christianity,
capitalism,
Marxism,
they saw all these huge,
you know,
explanations for how the world works and
said,
you know,
they're not working.
Look how bad communism failed.
Look how there's so much bullshit coming
out of this or that from religion.
It's not working,
we need to just get rid of all of it.
We're going to deconstruct this,
we're going to break it down to its
power dynamics,
and then we're going to look at it in
terms of who has master hood over over
who,
who's oppressing what,
whereas dominance and it's just kind of
grown.
It got picked up in the,
in the academic culture in the 19
sixties.
That's how old this stuff is,
and then it took this huge turn in the
19 nineties and get really vicious and
that's where it really got.
You know,
that's when it turned intersectional
actually.
That was during the political correct
days.
That's,
that's when the political correct thing
kind of blew up.
Yes.
When all this stuff was coming out,
so that would have been late.
Nineteen eighties is really when all of
this political correctness stuff started
coming out at the academy and then a few
years later you see it coming all over
politics,
which typically what happens,
it starts in the academy.
A few years later it leaks into the
culture and politics or media or detect
sector.
Now,
whatever it happens to be,
the stifling of creativity is the most
disturbing part about it like this,
the agreement that South Park and the
simpsons are a real problem.
It's so bizarre because here's the
thing,
if they miss the mark and it's not
funny,
it won't work and then it'll be a bad
show and no one would like it,
but if it's funny,
there has to be something about it that
people find ironic,
satirical.
There has to be something about it that
people are enjoying.
It has to point to some truth and the
denial of this and instead like to
saying,
oh,
it's white males that are causing this
problem and you shouldn't attack this or
that,
or the subjects that are off limits and
social justice should never be attacked
like the
to agree to that it.
It's so.
It's so preposterous.
This is life.
We're talking about.
This is literally a nuance of life.
All the various strange things in the
spectrum of human behavior and and all
the things that you encounter in life
and to segment and limit what is and is
not what's off limits.
It's not off limits based on race,
based on things that a person can't
control at all.
You're just born white,
so if you're born white,
you're born and oppressor,
you're victimizer,
and if you're a white male,
you're a fucking piece of shit and you
can say that white,
Hetero male in particular.
Oh God.
I mean,
I've seen so many tweets from people
that mean so many virtue signaling
tweets,
but one of my favorite ones is this
feminist who said,
all white,
a white straight men are trash unless
proven otherwise.
The thing right?
All of us,
all of us,
50 million of us have been give or take.
You know how many gay folks there are?
Trash,
trash,
no problem.
Proven.
It's proven otherwise improve.
You're not right.
How do you do that?
That's a lie.
You have to be an outlaw.
Know where they asked us to problematize
allyship too.
You see there's power dynamics.
Once you say,
Hey,
I'm an ally,
now you've made it so that you have like
a shield where people can call you a
white supremacist anymore and you are
acting on behalf of other people in your
speaking for them,
so you now have assumed power that we're
reproducing the same power dynamics.
That was my mind comp per paper that
rewrote my income was about allyship and
they were like,
okay,
you didn't prevalent allyship.
Yeah,
we had two of them that did mountain
comp.
One of them we just more or less
replaced whites would replace Jews with
white men and you literally took mine
comp.
The actual words from mind calm and put
it in this paper and replaced the word
Jews with the word white men and they
accepted it.
Well,
we had two papers that did mind
comprehend so that one did not get
accepted with the quotes that you guys
use.
I mean,
so that one was.
What we did was we took the whole
document on online and we just searched
the word Jew and we just started picking
sentences and paragraphs.
So what was it that at the end it was
something like,
if we don't combat whiteness,
it's going to be the funeral wreath for
mankind that's grayed out now.
They didn't.
Yeah,
they didn't.
They didn't accept that paper though
because that paper,
uh,
turns out was written from the
perspective of a white lesbian who hated
her own whiteness.
And they said that it was positioning
her as a good white and because she's
making herself out as a good way again,
allyship isn't all it's cracked up to
be.
She was making a problem.
She should have really been forwarding
the ideas of the black scholars that she
read way more and not talking about
herself so much,
even though it was a paper designed to
be talking about yourself,
which
what Hitler did.
So that's what we had to do.
Now the other mind
comp paper was about feminism and what
we did was he took the chapter,
it's chapter 12.
We took the chapter where he says,
this is why we should have the Nazi
party and what is expected of people who
are going to be part of it.
And we took out our movement,
our party,
he didn't call it a Nazi party in the
chapter,
but everywhere.
He's like our movement.
Took that out,
put in intersectional feminism,
and then modified the words and added
theory around it so that it would fly
and theory.
That's what they call it.
I love that word theory.
I love when feminist theory,
I love when they throw that around,
like,
what are you saying?
But you're saying things that like once
you say that you're,
you're good.
Like you've said,
you can say something ridiculous and
then say feminist theory.
And they're like,
oh,
it's in feminist theory.
Yeah,
that's the thing,
right?
Is so much of the stuff they come up
with.
Let me throw him an olive branch,
like so much of the stuff,
they come up with a creative idea.
Maybe there's something to some of this
stuff,
right?
But what they're putting forward as
hypotheses and then they're treating
them as conclusions so they're putting
forward this idea.
I saw one on twitter today.
It was something like there's about
South Park,
how it's been laundering racism into
society and making everybody comfortable
with racism and that's why everything is
so racist and people are shooting Jews
is because south park made it normal
that they're treating that as a
conclusion,
but that's a hypothesis,
right?
So we could test that.
It's conceivable that you could actually
try to parse out what variables need to
be controlled.
See,
you know,
South Park came out and started doing
these themes.
What,
how does it track?
Statisticians can do kind of amazing
things with that stuff,
but they're not doing that.
They're not testing it and testing it.
They're concluding it and they're using
theory to do so and they're going,
no,
no.
It's even bigger than that because why
don't they test it?
Well,
if they tested it,
and this is,
I'm not making this shit up,
you won't believe me,
but this is true.
If they tested it in the test showed
that their hypothesis was wrong,
they would say that the test was racist,
but the test is condoning racism and
that's why it didn't give them the
desired result.
How would you test something,
because I mean,
I'm not a statistician,
I actually am a mathematician,
but I'm not a statistician.
They're two different things,
so I'm not exactly sure how you would
test that,
but conceivably you could gather data,
survey data and see how attitudes have
changed.
Maybe you could track those kinds of
articles,
kinds of events that are coming out.
You could kind of pair that up with
what's been shown on south park who
aren't self park and track that with
attitudes.
There's no effort to do this.
They're like,
oh,
South Park presents these ideas,
which they then cherry pick because
there's other ideas that they don't talk
about their point the other direction.
These ideas are problematic.
That's the big word.
Theoretically that's a problem.
Why?
Because they,
and I'm not joking,
they literally believed that use of
language creates the power dynamics that
defined society.
So South Park's using language and
imagery that creates a power dynamic
that makes people more comfortable being
racist.
Boom.
Theory done tests needed.
No even attempt test.
Then if the test happened,
the test itself would be racist unless
it confirmed the hypothesis.
Right,
so they start with an agenda and then
you mentioned the word laundry,
which could your former guests,
heather,
talked about a ideal laundry.
I think that's important to the
listeners.
So what's really what's going on here
is,
um,
they're forwarding these hypotheses.
They treat,
they don't treat them as hypotheses and
then they write up a paper paper,
like we were saying is the absolute gold
standard of academic work.
They send the paper off.
The reviewers in our cases,
made our papers crazier every single
time.
So they push it further into the
ideology or the madness.
How does the review or do something like
that?
What,
what input did they get to have?
They said,
for example,
that we should problematize allyship if
we're gonna,
if we want our paper published,
we've got to problematize ally Shit.
I love that word.
Problematize everything.
Everything.
Dog Parks problem.
The problem with literally anything can
be problematized and looked at through a
feminist lens.
Does everything.
Every tool.
That's why we called it grievance
studies.
The grievance is they're massively.
Okay.
So then,
but the do the Homo transphobia trans
paper.
So we wrote this paper saying that
straight men are generally transphobic,
meaning in particular the kind of niche
weird definition that you see on the
Internet and activist sometimes that
they aren't interested in having sex
with trans people who have penises,
trans women who have a penis in
particular.
And so we said,
well that's the kind of transphobia.
And clearly the reason that they might
be transphobic is because they don't
practice putting things on their butts.
So if they start putting stuff up their
butts in particular,
we call it the paper dildos.
So you can imagine what we were saying
that she put up the paper was called
Dildo.
No,
that was the,
that was the nickname we gave it.
The paper was called going into the back
door.
Really,
really go,
going in through the back door.
There's a lot of technical words that
one get published published.
So we argued that,
that uh,
if straight men just penetrated
themselves and had their girlfriends
pegged them through exposure therapy,
you know,
you start small and then work your way
up.
You can remediate transphobia.
Yeah.
Will make them less transphobic.
So as a self penetrating or having your
girlfriend peg you,
you can be less transphobic and they
thought this is great.
So we base this off of off of eight
interviews.
It really 13 interviews,
but with men and I say really a 13.
There were 13 interviews documented,
but five of them were gay people,
not even straight people,
so they don't really apply.
So then we have these eight interviews
with straight men.
We made.
One of them are conservative and he's
just so we could just put in like,
you know,
crazy things that a conservative might
say about this.
And they were like,
why don't,
why weren't there more conservatives
participating?
So I was like,
well I'm going to run with this.
I wrote this whole thing.
We invited six conservatives to
participate and only one accepted.
And to kind of summarize why in the
world,
and this is in the paper,
in the words of one,
I don't want to be a part of some stupid
liberal study about shoving things up
your butt.
And they published that in.
Oh my God.
So we wrote this
retracted article going in through the
back door right there.
Oh my God.
Now did they contact you after they were
tracked your article and they go,
Hey,
you guys are fucking assholes.
You're wasting our time.
We spent hours reviewing your papers.
We got a couple of pretty bitter
responses.
But mostly no.
Mostly they've kind of put their head in
the sand and kind of avoided talking to
us that what I was saying before the
show started that I read one article
that was really diminishing the impact
of what you guys have done.
Saying like what?
It's not a big deal.
They were trying to make it seem as if
what you guys had written was just a
prank.
That's not what.
That's absolutely false.
Yeah.
There's a lot of papers that seemed like
parody that make it through that you
guys aren't writing.
Oh yeah.
We could pull up one about how hot wings
and like there's a TV show,
spicy ones or something like that.
About hot wings.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The Youtube show.
Yeah.
So they had a whole one's hot one's.
That's what it was.
They had a whole,
uh,
there is a paper out there about that
show and it's all about how,
you know,
hot sauce has everything to do with
masculinity and being manly and they
didn't have enough women on the show
because it's sexist in the hot hot
sauce,
I think was a sexist part and it has all
these bizarre concluded.
We cited that in the paper we wrote
about hooters.
We're putting in the part that
masculinity contests of eating the hot
wings who can eat more hot wings and
then they say,
Oh,
I ate 20 hot wings.
Ask out the hooters girl and eating show
hot ones is problematic.
Problematic.
There's an ally,
but that's a real paper,
right?
So we cited that paper.
It's real.
There are thousands of papers like this
spectacular food,
gender and celebrity on hot ones.
And so as a professor,
he probably teaches this stuff to
students,
right?
So now everything's problematized and
this is what credentials him.
You get seven in general,
you get the says it's a woman.
Years ago she wrote it,
but who's the other one?
Tisha,
at the end who wrote that introduction.
Oh,
what's the difference?
There's two people there.
Oh,
it's a commentary.
Is it?
Is it an article about the article?
Yeah,
that's probably what's going on.
His commentary and criticism.
Yeah.
This is.
It looks like.
I mean,
I haven't read this specifically,
but wait a minute,
listen to the first statement.
Food media have been recognized as
cultural artifacts that referenced
culturally and historically specific
ideals of gender,
drawing on the simultaneously mundane
and omd food as a medium for
interrogating,
interrogating ideas about feminism and
identity performance.
What I was telling you,
shut the fuck man.
This is like everything we talked about.
This is such unbelievable horseshit.
No,
this person is teaching at Central
Michigan University.
Yeah.
This is for real.
This is real,
and so there is now a,
an ever expanding group of these folks.
They teach.
Do you want to read more of it as we
didn't find this and criticism section,
the author's introduced a diverse sample
of case studies that demonstrate the
emergence of feminist ideas in and
through food media.
Oh yeah man.
Fuck.
Are you worried about that?
Getting a job,
a real job,
go out there and work,
do something that someone wants to pay
for something of value,
engagement with hot sauce.
It was so crazy and this is what they're
teaching our kids.
Racial assumptions inherent to post
feminist food culture.
Oh yeah.
I was going to write a paper about how
cornbread is being gentrified and that's
why I will never get over racism because
white people are making like pumpkin
spice cornbread.
Just something that I tweeted the other
day about some what Gad sad tweeted it
and I retweeted it about some.
Some woman was taking back bone broth.
I saw that.
Yeah,
it's good.
What in the fuck are you talking about?
People cooking bone broth?
Thousands and thousands of years getting
nutrients from the food.
You problematized it.
Look at this.
Queer woman of color wants to decolonize
bone broth.
Stop appropriating my culture.
Gad said he's awesome.
That is so fucking preposterous.
A queer woman of color.
So what I'm saying man,
there's a thousand papers like this out
there for everyone.
We wrote a thousand of them that you
might as well written.
Well,
you couldn't tell if we did or didn't.
That's part of things.
People can't differentiate what we've
done.
In fact,
not only can they not differentiated,
they give us an award so they can't
differentiate it from the stuff that's
already out there and there's stuff
that's already out there as polluting
people's minds.
You guys,
you guys,
at least you used to work in academia,
you work in academia.
What is,
how,
how were your peers treating this?
There are.
Well,
Pete has,
is going to have a lot to say about that
I think,
but for me,
I've had two from academic people.
I've had two kinds of responses,
but the overwhelming uh,
but some of those are like,
ah,
you guys.
And then the overwhelming of them are
the same thing over and over and over
again.
And I mean a lot of people.
Thank you so much for doing this,
but I can't,
don't tell anybody.
I'm just trying to get a job.
I'm up for tenure.
I can't talk about.
Thank you.
This needs to go and that's everywhere.
It's everywhere.
You can't proceed through academia now
unless you bow to this stuff.
Ten years sounds like tyranny.
It did.
The whole thing sounds preposterous.
That you can keep a job for life.
Well,
the idea was supposed to be that you
work your ass off for a few years and
then you.
It was supposed to be to defend academic
freedom so you get tenure,
then you can go forth and put out some
crazy ideas,
really like dig into some stuff and they
can't fire you for coming up with weird
stuff and then people would argue about
it.
But now it's kind of become the
situation where people get into this,
they get in their job,
then you can't get rid of them.
Right,
right,
right.
What is there a way to fire people?
Well,
if they do something like sexual
harassment and usually you can find a
way around the tenure thing.
So what is it like for you now?
You are actually super uncomfortable or
people upset at you?
I'd say they were enraged.
You know what I mean?
The only,
the only thing I can think of,
it's like if you taught at a Christian
school and then you went in and took
videos and posting them on youtube of
suffocating the Bible and then just
walked into the school.
So I think it's kind of similar in that
they,
they have bought hook,
line and sinker into microaggressions,
trigger warning,
safe spaces,
diversity and issues there.
There are no,
there's no questioning.
There's a.
and it's something for me that makes me
deeply uncomfortable when my students
can ask questions when,
when they,
they can't.
They're just uncomfortable to voice
their opinions about things and I think
that that peep to say the least.
A lot of people are enraged at me,
but exactly what Jim said.
Some people will come in like,
oh,
thank you so much.
Like I know,
but again,
I can't be public about what is the
ratio.
I mean for me it's like 95 percent
people who are really happy it happened
and can't let it be known,
but I'm not,
you know,
facing these people
full everyday.
Well,
you know,
through the videos from evergreen state,
you can see Bret Weinstein's
interactions with not just students,
but also some of the professors that
were there,
there were some of these preposterous
people that he had to work with that are
buying in Hook,
line and sinker to this stuff and they
live in these insulated world and they
just,
they,
they create these people that also want
to stay inside these insulated worlds
and then it just sort of stew in these
ideas and then again go out into the
real world and they think they're better
people as a result.
Yeah.
So that's a big trick to doing the good
work because to like question this,
maybe to look at it and say,
ah,
you know,
that kind of looks like bullshit,
but I don't know.
A lot of these guys are left leaning.
People are outright leftists.
A lot of them want to do the right
thing,
right?
They really do.
These people really care about
progressive agendas,
you know,
getting over any lingering
discrimination that's going on,
racism,
sexism,
et Cetera.
They really want to do the right thing.
Good for them.
Right.
That's what we want,
but they actually have to question or
like run county,
you think of that like as a river of
morality,
running through them to their mind they
actually have to go upstream a little
bit and that's hard and it feels weird.
You have to say,
wait a minute,
maybe this scholarship,
maybe this stuff isn't the best way to
do it,
but then the first thought you have as
well,
these guys are these people in these
disciplines.
Grievance studies are are fighting
racism,
so if I go against them then I'm going
against the people fighting racism,
so maybe I'm helping racism and what we
keep.
If we get any criticism,
that's what it always is.
Being racists,
you're a tool of the right,
etc.
Etc.
You're racist or we are outright
racists.
Outright racist and accusEd of being.
Alright.
If you disagree with any of this stuff,
I get accused of being outright all the
time.
I lean so far left universal healthcare,
universal,
basic income,
free school,
I think.
I think education should be free.
I think we should paY for,
I believe in a lot of socialist ideas.
Totally,
but I'm right wing because I make fun of
people that want to study problemization
of dogs.
Fucking really worried.
That's where it is.
If you look at like whether I support
gay rights,
women's rights,
I'm all,
I'm all right.
I'm on board with all that shit.
Take more of my taxes.
I can,
I can.
I can afford to pay more if I really
believed that people are going to get
real healthcare and real education.
Fucking very happy.
Very happy.
Yup.
if I thought it was all being
appropriated and used correctly.
Fuck yeah.
Let's,
let's make the world a better place.
So that's the thing,
right,
is if all this scholarship that they
were doing on race and gender,
although that's important stuff,
right?
So if they're doing that right,
why wouldn't you want to be behind it?
But they're not doing it right.
HOw do I know?
Because I made up papers about dog
humping and made up the conclusion
before I wrote the paper and then boom,
they publish it and given an award.
If I can start with the conclusion and
then work backwards to that conclusion,
then I'm not doing rigorous scholarship.
I'm making shit up.
Well also there's no room for dissent
and there's absolutely zero and in
academia you can't even.
You have to teach whatever the moral
orthodoxy is.
So just imagine this going into
university.
You're trying to your young mind,
you're young kid and I'm deeply
concerned about these kids are going and
they never hear the other side of an
issue about immigration.
They never hear the other day so that
they become brittle over time.
So when they hear it,
they just,
they don't know what to do.
They're shocked by it.
Professors are terrified that they'll
get a complaint.
They'll hAve to go to the diversity
board.
I've been told that I'm not allowed to
render my opinion about protected
classes when I had that ethics and I
teach ethics.
I don't teach a class or two classes.
I've also.
That's a great question.
Thank you for asking me.
I've asked for a definition of protected
classes,
a list of protected classes.
I didn't receive any.
Uh,
you can be criticized for.
I cannot,
I cannot offer for it.
yeah.
Yeah.
I cannot offer under.
Oh no,
no,
no.
So yeah,
it was up on a title nine violation.
I'm not,
I'm up for a violation of title nine
violation.
That title nine title nine violation is
serious shit.
I.
Federal discrimination law in
universities.
Yeah.
What'd you do?
I can't talk about it.
It's okay.
But,
but among the other things that came out
in that meeting where,
uh,
I'm not allowed to render my opinion
about a protective class.
And so for example,
uh,
I can't,
so I know are covered under a protective
classes.
you can't have an opinion on homosexual
people.
I can have an opinion,
but I can't.
What if it's a positive opinion?
Well,
so the example that was used in class
was evident.
Evidently I made a comment.
Okay.
So let's take a step back.
So this is an ethics class and I was
talking about how a sexual choice does
not fall into the realm of morality.
So if,
If a guy's gay and he likes another guy,
that's just not a moral thing.
That's just preference or just is what
it is,
like a matter of taste and some,
I don't remember the whole thing,
but someone in someone in the class
said,
well,
you know,
you shouldn't have tastes or something
or you shouldn't have,
and I can't remember the exact frame
because I'm getting this third hand from
the,
from my violation.
You know,
my time came to someone else.
Somebody said in class,
well what about this?
And I,
I made the comment,
I said,
everybody has something.
Everybody has a preference.
Like you can't say that no one had a
preference.
I said,
again,
it would be as if it was,
it would be as if I said,
well,
you know,
I don't want to date someone who's 400
pounds.
So that comment then got turned into
something when they called somebody else
in the office of diversity inclusion
called someone else in and it was made
that I was rendering my opinion about
people who were 400 pounds when my.
What I was doing is saying that
homosexuality itself,
there's no,
there's no reason to give that.
It's just not a moral thing,
but people lump it in,
but the main point of this whole thing
is that we have situations in which
professors can't talk about protected
classes.
Students are afraid to ask questions.
Everybody's walking on egg shells and
the students aren't learning and phrases
are taken out of context.
Phrases are taking out of context now.
Now if you want a place to go to
celebrate whatever the raining,
more orthodoxy is in the university is a
great place for you.
Did you explain what you meant by saying
that?
You like saying you don't want to date
people over 400 pounds.
Did you explain the context of the use
of.
She wasn't interested in the context of
it and the trend.
He didn't even say he doesn't want to
date people over 400 pounds.
He said it as exactly as I phrase it as
a hypothetical.
Right,
so their entire thing,
and if you had said maybe I don't like,
I don't want to date people over seven
feet tall.
Maybe you could have got away with that.
Yeah.
I don't think people over seven feet
tall or protected class,
you could have got away with that even
though it's still basically the same
thing.
It's a preference issue.
So I mentioned this to one of my
colleagues and he said to me,
oh you,
that's.
You can't say that.
You should never have said that.
And I said,
really?
Why?
He said,
well,
you should have said,
we'll,
I don't like dating blue or green
people.
I'm like,
why?
They're they know that they,
they don't even know blue green people
who is coming to around man and then
they become a protected class.
Then someone goes back and looks at what
you said 10 years ago about blue or
green.
So that's how I get fired and that's how
that works.
So if you look at all this stuff then
coming out about victimhood culture and
how it propagates and how it develops,
and that's one of the things.
It's called competitive victimhood.
You could call it additive competitive.
That's the formal term.
People who study this love that
wonderful people are fighting over who's
a bigger victim.
Did you see it all the time?
It's like you see people in society,
It's like,
oh,
the black lives matter.
People go nuts and then all of a sudden
the white supremacists are out and
they're like,
oh,
white people have it hard too.
The second day,
the second somebody hears,
oh,
black people have a hard somebodIes got
to be like white people have it hard
too.
That's competitive victimhood and so
then when you have like a moral economy,
if you will,
where you can kind of cash in,
gain status or gain access to to
speaking or whatever it happens to be by
holding a certain status of victim hood
or grievance.
Then you're gonna.
Find people competing to find ways to
get that for themselves.
Everybody's going to go.
I mean you have the infrastructure
there.
Everybody's goIng to go after trying to
maximize their own utility within that,
so people over seven feet tall aren't a
protected class yet,
but the second they realize that they
might be able to cash in on it.
They might lobby for it.
Edited victimhood,
grievance jockeying.
It's been also,
I've called it grievance jockeying,
I think gets out since you mentioned
him,
called it the oppression olympics.
Yep,
yup.
Yeah.
It's wonderful times,
but it really is.
If you look at the root,
so here's the thing that we thought
about extensively.
If you look at the root,
where is this stuff coming from?
All of this stuff is coming from these,
the canons of knowledge,
their bodies of literature,
they're peer reviewed and that's the
idea laundering thing.
yeah.
Which was.
So all of that stuff is coming from from
this and if you want to make.
If you want to get back to constructive
politics to get back to people having
conversations and that's a thing like
that's.
I think one of the reasons that your
show has been so successful is it's a,
It's a combination of authenticity with
you can have your totally willing to
have conversations with no holds barred,
right?
You can't have that in the academy,
so people need to go to you to hear
these thoughts and to wrestle with ideas
and to engage.
It's just if you can,
you can't really do it anywhere else
other than a podcast or you can't do it
in the academy,
but you can't even do it on the today
show.
They fired meghan carroll for asking why
is blackface racist,
which is a stupid fucking question.
No doubt,
and she's not a bright woman and in that
regard,
socially very clumsy,
clunky thing to say,
but they just fire a fire.
IT should have what they should have
done was brought in black scholars and
black intellectuals for a week just to
fucking griller.
Exactly,
and that would have been amazing
television,
but that attItude that you have is not
what they have.
So they want to punish the transgression
right.
Today.
Well,
I think they just want to stop and
I think they didn't like her anyway,
that's the word is they really didn't
enjoy her and that she wasn't a nice
person and she was immediate.
It was a learning moment,
right?
It was a teaching moment that's lost
now.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
but think about it in terms of what we
were talking about earlier where the.
The scholarships stretching back again
to the sixties,
you have this idea that all of socIety
is constructed out of power dynamics
that are mediated through language media
imagery and so she just now became
problematic and she put out ideas that
would be dangerous and poisonous not to
discuss the merits or demerits of not
something to work through.
Not something as a teachable moment.
She put out an idea that's dangerous.
She can't put out ideas anymore.
Well,
you know,
it was really interesting too.
She tried.
She was so disingenuous and how she
approached it is so obvious.
You know,
what a black person is it?
Why is it wrong for a black person
dressed as a white person?
It's not.
No one ever said that.
Why are you pretending you're just
setting it up so that you could say a
white
pursing were black,
black face about the other cultural
moment there too.
So like you said,
they bring in black scholars and at the
end of that she said,
you know,
I really listened to that and I didn't
know that and I was wrong and I'm
changing my mind.
There was a woman on twitter that said
her video,
look,
I retweeted it,
that it looked like a hostage video.
Anything that was missing was her
holding up a newspaper that showed the
day,
saw that it was australian woman,
go.
The whole thing is so fucking funny,
but that is one of the worst ways to
really dissect the ideas because first
of all,
there's the studio audience that fucks
everything up.
Second of all,
you have these massive time constraints
and then you have advertisers.
Then you have a bunch of executives that
are all cowards.
They're all just ready to pull the
trigger on anything.
Anytime they can blame you for anything
that went wrong and get rid of you or
fire you,
fire,
fire him,
get rid of them,
get out of him,
bringing the next person you know,
and then they'll,
they'll most likely do is to to show
they've learned.
They'll hire an all black crew,
right?
For the diverse crew.
That's all a matter of fact.
I think I've read it.
Are they doing that?
See,
see if they do that.
They're replacing meghan kelly with a
approve of color.
Make about where that works,
right?
It works.
You said they're cowards.
They're afraid they're going to damage
their brand or whatever it is.
Where does that work or who works on
that?
Bullies,
right,
so these people,
why are they so pervasive in the
academy?
Why are they say pr,
so pervasive and media.
They know they can bully these people.
They know that they can go lean on this
stuff and somebody is going to be
cowardly and then they're going to be
able to make something change in the
direction they want it to change.
You see,
even creeping into politics,
they,
they try to do it with policymakers.
You see it a lot more and a lot of other
countries.
Right now we're in this massive backlash
against it in american politics.
How's that going to the 2016?
Your progressive agenda gang.
Holy crap.
Well,
that is a part of the problem with the.
What are they saying?
So yeah,
look at this today.
As you know,
we're starting a new chapter in the
third hour of our show.
As it evolves,
it's evolving.
It's a fucking living being.
We want you to know the entire today
family will continue to bring you in
formative and important stories just as
we always have and look to black guys
and a brown chick
that's 100 percent diverse.
We got rid of the princess.
All diverse.
That's the thing.
The way that diversity is defined.
If you had a panel,
it was just black guys.
It would be 100 percent diverse.
Yeah.
So they've redefined the word diversity.
They need to find the word inclusion.
So,
but to people outside the academy,
they,
they think,
oh,
diversity,
it's a great thing.
Right?
But that's not what it means.
It means kind of when everybody has the
same ideas about something and it's also
when you,
if you're enforcing diversity for what
we have to,
we would have to find out.
Like ultimately the goal is to find out
what,
what causes people to succeed and
especially succeeding in something as
benign as talking.
Right?
You're just talking.
That's all you're doing.
So what causes someone to succeed and
talking.
What makes their ideas valuable would
make some someone you'd enjoy listening
to and then finding like what?
What impediments?
There are two that in all the various
communities and fix it at the root
level.
What doesn't work is saying,
we need one chinese lady,
we need one black guy and we need one
white guy.
Because if you do something like that,
you're not going to get the best show.
Nope,
you're not going to get the best.
Well,
you're not even guaranteed to achieve
the goal you're claiming.
So it's,
again,
it goes back to theory in theory and
theory in terms of postmodern critical
theory that this stuff's all based on
that we studied.
The idea is that if you have a
particular identity now you have a
particular view of the world and people
have other identities have different
ones and in fact there's this whole
thing called standpoint epistemology
that says that if you have a
marginalized identity,
you know more about the world and other
people because you live in two worlds at
once.
So the the idea is,
oh,
if we get a black guy in here,
he's had a different life experience,
therefore he can speak truly to that.
If you get a chinese lady in here,
she can speak to that.
So on and so Forth.
So the guests is that by virtue merely
of bringing in people who look different
with different races or genders or
sexist or sexualities,
then you automatically get a diverse set
of opinions,
but that doesn't work.
That's not how that actually works.
You could take people of every race,
educate them on the exact same social
justice curriculum and they all think
exactly the same thing,
but at least in something like hosting
the today show you are just talking once
you put these sort of diversity
standards or something like mathematics.
No.
yeah,
that's.
That's when things get super.
And so
they're trying to do that a little bit
tweeted that thing.
I wroTe about the mathematics and they
wanted people to sign an equity,
which is another word that they've
cooperated.
They wanted folks to sign an equity
statement and a diversity statement,
and the thing is,
explain,
explain what they're trying to.
That you,
you,
you have a commitment to diversity.
Yeah.
You have a commItment to diversity and
you have a commitment to equity.
And so equity does not mean treating
people equally.
It's not like you have a commitment to
equality,
which is what we should all have a short
material quality.
Uh,
it's equity is defined differently.
It's to make up for past injustices are
to make up for some deficiency that has
occurred somewhere along the line.
So yeah,
affirmative action is an equity
movement.
It's to treat people differently in
order to level the playing field.
Yeah.
So it's not treating people,
it's not treating people equally.
And that's the key thing.
It sounds like it is,
but it's not.
It's a word that they've smuggled in
straight out of the literature.
Again,
it's again,
out of all the stuff comes back to the
literature.
So if you look at the word equity in the
dictionary,
you get one definition.
But if you look at the word equIty as
they're applying it and sociological
definitions,
it's a very specific thing that means
something slightly different from what
people assume.
So here's the question.
You should ask somebody.
Anytime you hear someone use the word
equity,
just ask.
Oh,
I'm.
I'm curious,
why didn't you use the word equality?
Can,
can you.
Can you think of it?
Would the sentence be the same with the
meeting?
Be the same?
Well,
the meaning is not the same.
That's why they used equity and not
equality.
Equity is a finance word.
That's why it's weird.
He's also fun.
So they don't make up new words,
right?
They go,
yeah,
they call up,
they change and then they smuggled
diversity inclusion,
these academic papers and they come up
with these ideas.
They start with their conclusion,
they push it through,
it gets published and that's just like.
It's like the academic equivalent of
money laundering.
Money laundering work.
Yes.
You take some money,
you got,
you know,
ill gotten money,
you put it through this shell company or
this thing or the other thing and it
comes back to you.
And now it's had illegal trail that
makes it legit.
Right?
Well here you take some prejudice.
You write it down as an academic paper.
You published the thing,
it gets the academic standard stamp on
it.
It's the gold standard of knowledge now
and now.
This is this prejudice you started with
now looks like legitimate knowledge that
can go straight in the classroom.
It can go straight to exactly.
Activists or policymakers.
It's a real problem.
Yeah.
And then really funny though that you
get it is that's bret weinstein said
that weinstein said that and that's what
it comes out.
The other side is knowledge.
So then they think they have knowledge
or paper about the dildos.
The guy said this paper is an important
contribution to knowledge.
Who is it that the reviewer one?
I think out of the viewer,
what?
Who the fuck are you Important
contribution to knowledge.
I would hope reviewer one was just
hitting a bong right
before big data was laughing,
laughing at the whole college.
What kind of person gets attracted to
whole heartedly agreeing to these
ridiculous ideas?
Like what?
What are the people like to gray
question.
I think it's people who want to save the
world.
Well,
we,
I think we would all like to save the
world.
Yeah.
I'm much more cynical than they.
Yeah,
they've got to know they've got,
they've got this idea that,
I mean we talked a moment ago about
about privilege and we kind of brushed
real close to the idea that it fits kind
of like original sin.
And so they see that the downside of
privilege,
the opposIte side,
discrimination or racism,
sexism,
et cetera.
Hate is the big word.
You know,
fight hate or he's he,
he's using hate.
This is hate speech.
That's where I think they got the term
that's like the evil thing.
You're born with privilege.
That's like original sin.
So what do they want to do?
They want,
they want to fIx the save the world by
clearing out the evil of privilege,
by clearing out hate from the world.
For them.
Utopia means nobody hates.
And by hate we mean something like
racism,
sexism,
etc.
So it's a noble idea,
but then when you start looking at it
and it's ridiculous way,
like you're born with privilege and now
you're just stuck with it,
right?
What can you do?
It's original sin.
You can be sorry for it.
You can try to be an ally and work it
off.
You can check it.
Whatever the hell that means.
You can do a lot of things,
but you can't actually atone for it.
You can't get over it.
You can't get rid of it.
Then you get this situation where it's
like they really,
really need to take desperate measures.
Like,
let's lock it all down.
Let's,
let's tell these people that they're
wrong.
Let's try to point out how white
supremacy is in them because they're
white.
LeT's point out how masculinity is an
ideology that needs to be destroyed.
That was Lisa Wade.
She wrote that last year.
That is an ideology that needs to be
destroyed.
Yeah.
It needs to be masculine because trump,
and this is the thing,
right?
I think in the past couple of years,
of course,
before trump,
it wasn't new.
They had other avatars.
I think there's a lot of anger and
frustration,
justifiably slow at trump and they see
this and so I read so many other,
usually op-eds,
not their academic pieces and it's like
men are like this,
men are blah,
blah,
and you can tell they're just talking
about trump,
but they can't touch him.
So they're pissed off and they tried to
take it out on all men.
I think that's like a huge thing.
They see these problems,
they exaggerate the problems.
They practIce problematizing and that's
a thing,
rIght?
They practice this stuff.
You go to school,
it's in the general ed curriculum.
Maybe they major in this stuff.
You get good at fInding problems.
I was just talking yesterday.
came over.
I never actually,
I got to los angeles a couple of times
before,
but I've never been to the beach.
I never actually made it down,
so I went down to santa monica,
go to one of these burger places right
on the,
on the right by the pier and it says
that this is the burger that made santa
monica famous and immediately you saw
the hot ones thing.
right?
I was like,
there's a paper on this,
you see the problems here.
You have this manly double being
marketed.
That's what made santa monica famous.
Oh,
so maInly food culture is the kind of
like colonialism that goes and makes a
city become a city.
It makes a place into a place.
And you could.
I could write a paper about that in
three days.
Do you have to have credentials to write
a paper,
a phd?
No,
technically not.
And that's a sad thing because what
their response to this has been,
oh,
we're going to screen better to see who
is actually writing these papers so they
can't trick us,
but that's bullshit.
So we trick you.
The point is that the scholarship is
that it should stand on its merits of
the arguments solid if the research is
good and they thought our research was
good.
So my point about the dog humping thing,
it should leave it the way it is.
If they're saying that this is such an
important piece.
Right.
Well,
I mean I would walk back on that one
because we did make up the data and
falsifying data is not cool.
Well,
what data would be incorrect?
Like what?
We didn't even go to the dog park.
We definitely didn't ask anybody about
their dogs or their genitals or anything
that you could have similar results.
We said that there's a dog crapping on
another dog's head in the paper and like
that didn't happen.
I'm sure that didn't happen and maybe it
did happen though.
I mean this is insane,
but we had other papers that didn't do
that.
Fat bodybuilding didn't do that.
The one that's the one that joke's on.
You didn't do that.
There was no made up data and most of
our papers.
And why shouldn't those stand?
Right.
Why should they stand by those?
Exactly.
I can get it because we can't
differentiate real scholarship from
bullshit because they're in this crazy
eco system in which their ability to
make discerning judgments about things
has been dulled because they put an
agenda before the truth.
I keep seeing all these academics coming
like they get their got you moment on
us.
They're like,
oh,
I read your paper.
It's actually a real paper.
It's good.
Yeah.
How crazy is like,
yeah,
thanks For noticing.
You know,
asshole.
That's exactly what we were trying to
do.
We weren't writing just stupid pranks.
The dog park papers pretty funny,
but we were actually trying to learn
what's going on there.
Thanks for noticing somebody finally
did,
but that means of course they don't want
to admit that we actually learn this
stuff because then when we say it's
shit,
they're stuck with somebody who knows
what they're talking about saying it
sucks and they don't want that either.
No.
When you said these people that are
trying to save the world,
like what?
What do you really mean by that?
I think there are the people who are
trying to build the kingdom of god on
the planet earth.
You know,
to draw a metaphor,
religious metaphor.
There are people who see an eVil and
they want to purge the world of that
evil by any means necessary,
and the evil being like privilege,
privilege,
privilege and white supremacy,
new religions,
patriarch.
Christianity goes down.
It's just a game of thrones is the onlY
reason you need new gods are because
people don't believe in the old gods and
so we have these religious modules or
what have you in our brain and the new
religion is intersectionality and we see
really is what it is exactly what it is.
You know the parallels are wrIting about
that and talking about that for years
studyIng religion psychology for years
and it's.
It's all over the listening is political
correctness
is paralleled with blast.
For me,
it's the same parallels of harrison the
apparels.
That's exactly right.
I mean it's,
it's so stunning how easily people sort
of slide into these preconditioned
slots.
Huge.
The one difference,
and I think this is a key difference,
the reason that it's easier,
and I mentioned this to pendulum when we
did a talk and he just couldn't believe
it.
The reason that it's easier to talk to
christian for example,
about faith or about their religion is
because at the end of the day it comes
down to faith.
These people don't have any faith.
They have knowledge,
quote unquote.
They have their bodies of scholarly
literature which are ideal honored.
That's what they have,
so they can point to these things and
say,
well,
I don't have any.
I know.
How do you know?
Well,
robin deangelo's,
white fragility.
How'd you study?
There's a study.
Yeah,
there's a study.
There's a study,
I know household stuff.
Some of those studies are written and
trust them and you shouldn't trust them
either.
Yeah.
Well you see that even in nutrition when
you see it in everything this,
this in in terms of like almost a
religious or religion,
like accepting.
Exactly.
Have specific ways of eating or specific
ways of communicating,
specific ways of being.
It's just so strange how people seem to
have this natural inclination to adopt
predetermined patterns of behavior.
Right?
Yeah.
I think actually there's pretty decent
understanding of that from from the
perspective of moral psychology.
You've got this idea that somebody has
has seen something as good so it
elevates them.
It makes them better,
so clean eating might be good,
right?
Whatever clean eating means.
For some people it's vegan.
For some people it's like all you eat is
grass fed beef,
who knows,
but you've got clean eating and you've
got dirty eating and he'd go into the
clean thing and so you've got this kind
of like purity thing and eventually you
take this so seriously that it becomes
kind of a sacred value to you.
Well,
what's sacred mean?
You know,
we have this kind oF vague sense,
oh,
you know,
holy this,
that,
that's sacred and it's something really
important to somebody.
Or what it really means is that it's
taken on so much moral important to
somebody that they no longer will allow
it to be questioned when something
sacred.
It's now been removed from the sphere of
being doubted,
questioned or whatever.
And so when you have this idea of Like
that,
um,
let's say that that privilege is the
cause of,
of racism,
and you've elevated that are the problem
with everything in society,
even then you've elevated that to a
sacred value that can't be questioned.
You can't say maybe there's another
dimension to it.
That's when you start getting these
kinds of religious like behaviors.
You start getting these,
these problems because you've got a
place where it can't be a question.
Be made fun of.
If we're talking about the comedy
earlier,
this is killing comedy,
right?
It's absolutely killing comedy because
you can't make a joke because if the
joke goes a little bit wrong,
now you're.
You've committed a heresy,
you're a blasphemer,
they're going to be yes,
but no,
because people love when you go against
it.
That's
true.
So the weight of it is there,
but when you resist it,
people scream and throw.
YeS,
yes,
yes.
So this is really interesting because if
we take their theory about humor at face
value,
right?
That you can only go against a power
thing.
So we say,
okay,
you know what?
We wrote a paper,
one of our papers,
the joke's on you was about that.
Let's say the right.
Why do people love it?
Well,
it's because everybody knows these guys,
these guys have power.
They're trying to pretend that they
don't have power,
that they are the victims.
They're the oppressed.
Meanwhile,
they're bullying everybody and
everything.
They're firing people for saying the
wrong thing in class.
You know,
whatever it is,
that's only possible if they have power
in the joke when south park makes fun of
like,
what was it,
pc,
principal or whatever.
When south park makes fun of that.
The only reason people laugh if their
theory is right is because they're
powerful.
If their theory's wrong because it's
just funny.
Then we can talk about something
different,
but if they're actually right,
if they're actually making a point here,
they're not recognizing that they're
admitting that they have seized a lot of
cultural power and that's why people
celebrate when you go back against
stuff.
That's why people have sent us some
emails,
like this is the greatest thing ever.
Thank you so much for doing this.
There's all this shit like you guys are
heroes,
blah,
blah blah.
Why?
Because they wanted to see you laughed.
Because it was funny.
As hell as why and why?
Because these people are there.
They're influencing the shit out of
stuff.
Yeah,
and if they weren't,
if they were just,
you know,
victims who don't have a voice,
who can't make any impact,
who aren't bullying people.
Every room you're like,
why are you bullying those guys?
Why are you being a dick?
Right,
but everybody thinks it's funny and why?
Because because they have real impact.
They haven't had a real impact.
Yeah,
and that's one of the things that we
really want to convey to people is that
this happens in the academy,
does not stay in the academy.
No,
it's spread.
It's spread throughout the world now and
I've,
I've read some articles about some
things that we've said on this show that
are just fucking completely preposterous
and taken totally out of context and
presented as some evidence of,
you know,
whatever transgression that's impossible
to defend.
It's very strange.
It's very strange time for,
for communication.
It's a very strange time for ideas now,
but I also think it's really exciting.
It's exciting that all this nonsense is
going on.
That's one of the things that are really
loved about what you guys have done.
It's exciting.
It's exciting that you guys have
infiltrated and had these fucking
dummies public.
Not just publish your shit,
but praise it.
Yeah.
I'd say how amazing it is that you wrote
a bit about fat bodybuilding acceptance
is this one fat shaming and fat
acceptance too.
Preposterous phrases.
There really are.
You know,
I mean you shouldn't be mean to people.
That's it,
but fat shaming because someone's fat.
No,
you can't call me fat because I'm not.
Fat doesn't work.
So that's real similar.
So that body of literature.
Here's something that I learned when I.
I read this is they don't use the word
obesity because this is really
interesting because obesity,
it gets back to what jim was saying.
Obesity is a narrative.
It's just a story.
So they use the word fat.
Excuse me.
So there's not obesity,
bodybuilding,
there's fat bodybuilding and there are
all these narratives,
so why would one want to buy into one
narrative rather than another narrative?
Why iS fat and obesity?
Because obesity is a medicalized
narrative where fat is just a
description.
They're rejecting medicalized terms.
Well,
they call it a health system.
I'm not making that up.
Health is a narrative.
It's a power structure were healthy and
thin.
People are imposing their view of how
bodies should be on an unhealthy,
been privileged,
like they'd look at you and you've got
all the [inaudible] your muscular too,
so you wouldn't just be straight white,
heterosexual,
cis,
etc.
I mean you've got health privilege and
you've got health privilege and
privilege.
Probably thin privilege also enable us.
You're really,
you're really stuck.
Good for you.
Falls into that.
So I'm privileged.
That's real.
That's a real one that they use and they
also claim to be a healthy at every size
movement.
You can be healthy at every size and
obesity is just a medicalized
narratives.
Yeah,
and that's really important though
because the point of that is to say if
your doctor tells you you're fat and
it's a health concern,
then you don't have to listen.
Yeah,
that is the.
I've read that before and they're read
an article by this woman who was
morbidly obese.
Charlotte cooper.
I don't use the mail order,
but she was talking.
She was also using really misusing some
studies on.
There was some there.
There.
There have been some studies on people
who are overweight and that there could
possibly be some health benefits to
being overweight.
These studies had been widely dismissed.
Now not only dismissed,
but they go in direct contrast to the
great volume of studies that show how
terrible it is for your health to be
that,
that fat and that heavy,
but this person,
I don't remember who it was,
why she was doing this,
but she was clinging to these one or two
studies that have been dismissed.
These are biased epidemiological studies
that have been dismissed,
but she was put putting them in this
blog as if this is some sort of evidence
that not only is it not unhealthy to be
fat,
but it might be healthy to be fast and
I'll think about this person in an
academic position as a professor
teaching young people to protect
particularly young girls,
particularly young girls who have eating
disorders.
Exactly.
Health a white privilege.
Oh my god,
is this real?
This is a real paper is definitely.
Oh man,
they think it's a.
I think it's like when the doctor says
you're overweight,
it's a concern for your health.
See that as a form
of fat shaming saying that they're not
all right the way that they are.
They're not Being accepted the way that
they are.
There was a power dynamic that healthy
people are imposing upon overweight
people.
they have myriad issues that they come
up with and I mean insurance.
Some of these complaints have got to be
somewhat real.
You know,
they don't make as many oversized
clothes plus sized clothes.
It's harder to get styles or there's
some legit stuff you know,
that they might want to say,
hey,
what can we do something about this?
But on the other hand,
the whole thing that like saying that it
has nothing to do with health,
it has nothing to do with your
triglyceride levels.
It runs it's anti evidence.
It runs in tHe face of every conceivable
piece of evidence.
There are teaching kids this,
they're in schools and there are
classes,
fat studies classes,
and there was an actual,
whoa,
whoa.
There's fat studies journal publIshed
the fed fat studies.
Jamie's going to bring it up.
I told you,
I told you 30 million people are waiting
to find out real journal of body weight
and this is what jim was telling me.
He's like,
when when we do this,
30 million people are going to now know
that there's something fat.
Now fat studies doesn't do what you
think it does.
You probably think,
oh,
fat studies,
you know what?
A triglycerides,
how much should you exercise?
Good diet.
How much sugar is too much sugar?
Well,
that is aBsolutely not what this journal
does.
Frozen a fat tail of immigration.
What the hell?
Rafting weight stigma.
Hold on a second.
Crafting weight stigma in swimming
classes.
A case study in Ireland,
so,
so I'm tellIng you,
you go to a swimming class,
you're going to go lose weight.
You take a take a fitness class or
something.
Whatever slimming classes are fatness in
temporary use a stigma against being
fat.
They they basically say fats bad for
you.
This one,
theorizing,
fat oppression,
intersectional approaches and
methodological innovations.
You just said a bunch of nonsense.
The oppression of fat people as built
into institutions pervades the cultural
landscape in effect.
Dude,
we could have written this and affects
the relationship and perceptions of
people of size,
people of size.
Is this introduction to the special
issue on flip size?
It's not the new people of color.
More people of color is a problem now
to.
Yes you can,
but you see there's people of color and
then there's bi poc,
which I don't know how you pronounce it
off,
it's bipap or what,
but uh,
that would be black and indigenous
people of color because they have even
more oppression than the other people of
color.
And they got a fight and yellow people
of color.
Yeah.
For example,
or probably brown.
Harvard can discriminate against asians
that are trying to get in,
let's tap our noses and just move on.
Right?
So,
so,
but then that's even a problem because
indigenous has recent recently been
branded a racist term because you're not
actually honoring.
Yeah.
You're not hitting the actual tribal
identity if you get right on the cutting
edge of this stuff.
It's like really going into meltdown
closeness is because it's too random.
Well,
yeah,
you're just.
You're not.
You're generalizing your chair.
What exactly?
Nez perce.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you can see again,
the competitive victimhood going on who
gets to claim more of the victimhood pie
and oh now we've got this thing about
people of color.
so they get,
you know,
victimhood status,
but why?
If that goes to all people of color
equally,
that's not fair because these people of
color even more dIscriminating it so
they should get more of it.
It's really,
they're fighting over a piece of a pie
of victim hood nus.
I love the canadian term first nations
first nation people.
It's,
it's a better term because really
fucking every single human being that
came to north America came from
somewhere else.
So it's just being a witch in the.
In the fap,
since we're talking about in the fat
bodybuilding paper.
Oh yeah.
I put in a star trek reference at the
end.
I love star trek.
I put in something like fat bodybuilding
is the final frontier for fat activism.
Oh,
they didn't like to go.
They didn't like that they said it was
so that we couldn't use the word
frontier because it evokes imagery of
the genocides America,
the american native americans,
to choose a different word.
yeah.
Yeah.
You're holy shit.
Think about frontier airlines,
right?
What's up with them?
They're in trouble.
Their whole worldview is so utterly
distorted and twisted and the things you
believe are totally untethered to
reality,
but yet you believe there's knowledge.
You believe it's knowledge because it's
published and think about what it does.
The students had picked this stuff up.
You go to college,
you picked us up,
you start majoring in it.
You could be majoring in something where
you actually learn to do critical
thinking,
to engage with ideas.
If your dIstrict,
if you're,
if you're disadvantaged going into
college,
that's your best chance to get out of
that situation is to grapple with great
critical thinking.
Learn some great skills,
whether that's,
you know,
engineering and the sciences,
something like that.
Whether it's even if it's you want to
get into like studying race in
sociology,
soft sciences,
or you want to get into just literature
do it honestly,
and you're going to get somewhere,
but you get into this stuff where you
can literally just make up your
conclusions.
What are you doing?
You're teaching these people how to
think about problems or seeing the
burger and the santa monica pier is a
problem.
Now I see it everywhere I go after I did
this for a year.
So you get the people in the habit of
seeing problems everywhere.
Are you helping them?
Are you getting them at a book about
this or anything?
You know,
we might one day that's a great idea for
a book.
The hard part is we could actually
probably write 10 books,
so condensing it down to a book,
usually you got an idea and you have to
blow it up to a book.
We have to condense this down to a book
and they're talking about the problem,
like just explaining what you've already
explained on this podcast and,
and,
and actually having those studies that
you did publish and the whole thought
process behind creating them will be a
great book.
We got a documentary happening about it.
Mike nina is a documented tarian from,
uh,
from Australia that got hooked up with a
z,
a white male.
He's not around.
He's half black,
half black watch album.
How we met mike.
oh yeah.
So,
um,
it's interesting because we were
starting out this project and then we up
talking and we couldn't talk to anybody
about it.
It's so hard to keep a fucking secret
this big.
Right?
You just want to tell people like,
you aren't gonna believe what I'm doing.
Can't tell anybody.
So we fInd a few trusted friends were
telling us one guy,
a buddy of ours,
and he's like,
oh my god,
I know a documentary ian,
who's making,
who's investigating all this shit going
on in the universities already.
He's already interested.
Would you guys be interested in this
will be a compelling documentary?
Would you guys be interested in talking
to them?
So we,
we get in touch with him and he's like,
listen,
you know,
I'll shoot this.
I think there's a,
there's a film here,
I think you're going to ruin your
career.
so that's what I'm going to film.
But in any case I'll film this,
but here's the deal.
I'm only going to shoot it if you commit
100 percent transparency.
Let me tell the full story.
honestly,
what's really happening?
You know,
we don't get to sugar coat anything and
make you guys look good.
And of course he thought we were just
gonna crash and burn.
That's the only reason I agreed to this.
I was sure that you guys got a torpedo
your careers like positive.
Yeah.
And so he thought It was going to be
that and you'd have to convince us to
let him show it because we wouldn't want
to.
But does he know that you don't work in
academia anymore?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But we were doing the project,
so we reached out to him and said,
well,
through the mutual friend,
how would it ruin your career?
Well,
I maybe would never get another job if I
wanted to go back into academia for
example,
or I mean I still,
it hasn't happened yet,
but you see people who do academic
misconduct get banned from ever
publishing academic papers again,
that could still come down for me.
I don't know what it probably won't,
but it might.
And if it does,
you knoW,
then if I tried to get a job working for
like a think tank or university or
anything that depends on that,
I'm locked out of that now.
So,
um,
especially it's going to ruin pizza
career too.
Let's be honest.
He works in,
he works in not just the university of
portland state,
you know,
it's like ground zero for you.
I don't know.
It's going to happen when it's over for
sure.
They're always like,
I'm not sure what's going to happen.
No,
it's best not to prognosticate too much
with this stuff you see now we talked
about bret weinstein and heather a
hiring.
They got firebombed right there.
Thing just blew up,
blew the hell up.
And then they got pushed out of their
jobs.
But in a sense it's like,
I don't know what I was talking to them
when we were in portland and it feels
like they kind of took the fall and
people are like,
whoa,
that's too far and I don't know if
that's the case or not,
but if so maybe that's too far.
like pushing people out of their jobs,
like students patrolling the campus with
bats,
trying to find brett to pull them out of
his car.
If he showed up like that,
I don't care who you are.
That's too far.
I mean that's not even civil society who
thought that was too far though the
students is not there,
but a lot of people,
like people saw this.
The role men is like.
Did you think it was too far?
Right?
I thought it was insane.
I think the government should have come
in and shut down the school.
Yeah,
tons of people.
Tons of people around.
I mean like everyday people who saw this
story think,
whoa shit,
this stuff's gone too far.
The fact that they're allowing that guy
to remain as president.
Oh yeah.
It's absolutely not.
Absolutely
not.
When there's that scene in the car,
wherever it was,
conference room or wherever it was,
when the kids were telling him to put
his hands down because he's being
aggressive with his hands,
he puts his hands down and they start
laughing.
I was like,
what in the fuck is this?
It is a system set up to where you can't
win is what it is.
Deliberate,
but it's hilarious,
but they were laughing at him.
He put his hands down.
They're like,
stop making hand gestures.
You're being aggressive.
He puts his hands down.
They started last.
Sorry last night and I didn't find it
funny.
I found it terrifying.
It's.
I find it terrifying for what it means
for all of us.
Yeah.
If that.
If that can happen at a college campus,
I mean that's where ideas are supposed
to be shared,
disgust explored,
etc.
If that can happen at a college campus,
everything's up for grabs at some point.
Was that college campuses really
strange?
It's really strange.
We're struggling now and have radically
radically down.
Yeah.
I mean they could literally go under
because of this.
It looks like it might happen.
Yeah.
It's too bad because when it was doing
well,
as brett was explaining,
it was a wonderful place to teach
because he could do whatever he really
cool stuff.
He could take them to the park and they
could do a class in the park.
They could.
He.
He could have a class where,
you know,
whatever.
Regardless of what he's teaching,
he could teach you about something else.
Crazy field trips somewhere,
you know,
all this stuff,
adventures with the students,
the creator of the simpsons go there to
speaking simpsons.
I think he was an alum from there.
It's such a shame because they're just
such decent people.
They're just such great.
They're both great.
They're smart too,
so really legitimately smart and
fiercely progressive,
progressive,
decent humans.
Of course that means they're outright
adjacent.
Fucking hilarious man.
These people.
It's a strange,
strange time for ideas,
but I think this is.
It's also subs.
It's some sort of a symptom of this
culture that we live in where everyone
gets to voice their opinion.
EverYone feels entitled divorced because
of social media,
because of this instantaneous ability to
post whatever you feel about anything.
Whether it's a comment on youtube or a
tweet or a facebook post,
this nature of everyone putting in input
instead of earning your right to be
heard,
you know,
through merit and through your work and
through people saying,
hey,
this guy is smart,
this girl has great ideas,
this person really has some good points.
That's tom.
Tom nichols ideas.
Before we used to criticize people from
a point of expertise.
Now people who have absolutely no
expertise feel that they're entitled to
not only criticized,
but have everybody else listened to the
criticisms.
I think you're onto something with the
social media,
right?
Because you post something and it gets
like four interactions and you're like,
why?
How come joe rogan's thing got like
4,000?
It's not fair.
Right?
And so there's this like kind of
competitive jealousy kind of thing going
on and I think we've seen that a lot.
You know,
these kind of,
you know,
people who don't have a lot to bring to
the table and they want to get,
you know,
maybe it's a spot on a podcast,
maybe they want to get on a conference
or something.
Speaker in a conference,
and we've seen this for years,
what happens is,
well,
you know you got some big name that's
coming.
Well,
let's just can him and say,
well,
he's a sexist.
He said this terrible thing.
Now he can't be at the conference or
will protest.
Get him out,
put one of our guys in or when they
start to get more power,
it's like,
let's make sure half of our people are
there or else we're going to make sure
that we sell your conferences racist.
Then that becomeS like just a hot mess.
Nobody wants to go to the conference.
It's not going to be financially soluble
so it falls apart.
I mean this stuff has been going on.
This seems to be what's going on and I
think you're touching something where
social media and tom nichols talks about
it to generating a kind of narcissism
where people feel entitled,
like I have a voice.
Nobody's listening to me,
but they should listen to me because
they of course think that their ideas
are great
and the rise of social media coincides
with shutting down.
Speakers absolutely occurs on campus.
It didn't use to happen that way,
used to be even if people protested it,
the speech went on and people debated
that person or the people got a chance
during the q and a section to challenge
these ideas.
That's what it's all about.
What it's supposed to be all about.
Yeah.
If you have a problematic person,
you have a person that you feel is at.
They have ideas that are questionable.
You bring in a person whose ideas you
feel our counter and you let the
audience see how these individuals
discussed these things.
When I was in highschool,
barney frank debated some guy from.
He was a very conservative person.
I forget what the.
There was a ridiculous conservative
group that had some really funny name.
Uh,
I forgot what it was,
but he was like,
this really can.
Ronald reagan style conservative and
barney frank was.
I think he was still in the closet back
then,
but he was this like very articulate,
powerful left wing guy and they did it
inside this a community center in our
high school,
whatever it was,
you know,
some auditorium.
And I got a chance to watch this one guy
talk about all these different,
what you know,
whatever it was,
gay marriage or whatever is conservative
ideas and values and a marriage should
be between a man and a woman and all
these different things that would today
at a lot of college campuses,
you'd want those shutdowns.
You don't want someone propagating these
ideas,
but barney frank came on after him and
eloquently dissected what was stupid
about it and what the constitution is
all about.
What makes America great is our freedom
and our ability to express ourselves.
And by doing so,
me as a 16 year old kid and the audience
got to see ideas,
dissected and ideas debated and see two
people from polar opposite perspectives.
just battle it out and let the best idea
win.
And I'm sure there was probably some
people that were in that audience that
came out of it with a different
perspective.
Like,
yeah,
gay people shouldn't get married and
marriage is supposed to be between a man
and woman.
I'm sure of it.
And that's what happens in a democracy.
Yes,
you're talking about the very foundation
of liberal society.
You're talking about John Stuart mill
here.
I mean,
did you talking about John Adams?
You're talking about the foundation of a
liberal society here and that's what the
scholarship runs that were.
We looked at runs directly counter to
this.
Remember the idea is that if people are
putting out language,
the idea that some people are going to
come away with a heteronormative idea or
a homophobic idea.
That's already a catastrophe.
Yes.
Show.
We can't allow it.
We got to pull the speaker wires like
demora event we've got.
We can't let that go on.
yeah,
that's my point is like what happened
where know these kind of interactions
between contrary ideas is so it's so
dangerous that one or two people could
possibly be shifted.
I mean even if it's thirtY percent of
the audience,
I mean who the fuck knows what?
What's gonna happen when people are
sitting there listening and who's to say
that you're right or you're wrong,
that the way to challenge ideas is not
pulling the plug on the speakers.
It's a better ideas.
If you,
if you fundamentally subscribed to the
idea that heteronormativity,
let's use it as the example of
heteronormativity is the power structure
that's holding down gay people and
preventing them from having equal
opportunities.
If you fundamentally believe that
anybody else getting convinced,
anybody being reinforcement of the idea
of heteronormativity isn't just a few
like 70 percent changed their mind and
30 percent stuck with it.
That's just bolstering the already
imagined to be completely dominant view.
It's really kind of anti progress,
right?
Because it views the idea that power
structures can't change.
They're always rooted in some identity.
Whoever has,
you know there's more straight people
than gay people are.
Okay,
so therefore straight people always have
power.
Therefore anything that reinforces
heteronormativity is going to be a
catastrophe.
That reinforces the next thing you know,
people are going to be beating gays in
the snow or something
that it's also the complete infant
stylization of young adults because
you're.
You're telling me these young adults
aren't smart enough to dIfferentiate
between good ideas and bad ideas.
Well,
if they're learning all this grievance
study stuff,
I just said their critical thinking is
getting hobbled,
but if you're a person who's a young,
progressive,
well read person who's got some rock
solid ideas about people being able to
live their lives without discrimination
and all the things that I'm sure we all
agree on,
and you sat and listened to some right
wing,
alright asshole spewing hate.
Is it going to change you?
It's gonna affect you.
Of course it's not.
So who is it going to affect?
Like who?
Who are these ideas going to reach?
Why do we assume that people are so much
more easily influenced than we are?
What,
what is that about?
this isn't this infant.
Teleportation is young adults.
Kids.
It's fucking nerve in the world.
And sharp corners.
Got to put a fucking cane off and hide.
Just published that.
A book,
the coddling of the american mind.
And,
and,
and uh,
I think if you look at [inaudible] work
and the heterodox academy and he's
fighting for this,
but we have infant infantilize people,
we've have infantilized students and I
don't,
I hope that the tide changing.
I don't know,
one of the things we wanted to do with
this project is give people the
opportunity to speak out and say,
you know,
they don't speak for me.
I want to hear what someone has to say
about immigration.
The other side,
quote unquote I want to hear which I
want to hear the best arguments because
then I want to engage them myself and
you know,
I also think that we should have people
of all.
I think it's a problem that people who
go into teaching.
I can't remember what the study I read
the overwhelming percentage of people,
college educators are on the left.
I'm on the left.
I think that's a problem.
I think that they need diverse voices.
diversity also has to be ideological
diversity and if you want people to be
less brittle and if you want people to
be less infantilized,
they have to hear the other side,
but they have to hear.
This is also a mills' idea.
They have to hear it from people who
believe it.
That's in John Stuart mill's book on
liberty is it's not enough to have heard
that.
The other side.
The argument from the other side exists,
you need to hear the best case put
forward by people who really,
really subscribed to it and then work
against that if you can defeat that,
than it deserves to be defeated.
Right?
Yeah,
and this is the thing I think in
general,
human beings,
we all put forth our best ideas and
we're all wrong.
MosT of the time we're all.
We can be a smart guy or a smart woman,
whatever.
We're all pretty stupid.
We put forth a lot of ideas.
Most of them are wrong.
It's true for everybody,
true for you,
me,
everybody and what we should really be
relying on his.
You know,
I put it on an idea and you're like,
well,
I don't know about that.
And so we start cutting away the
bullshit that I tuck tucked into my idea
of the stuff I didn't have.
Right?
We do that and now the idea that
survives that process is better,
and then somebody else comes along and
says,
wait,
wait.
That part's probably a little bit
bullshit,
but this you could add to it and then
make it better.
And then some of that's wrong and this
is the process of how we really produce
knowledge and it's a co two.
That's what gives us a vibrant culture
to write it as opposed to what we see
here,
where I can we,
the three of us can make up a
conclusion,
write a paper to support it.
And then if you criticize it,
you had to have criticized it because
you were sexist or because you were
racist.
If you do a scientific test that shows
that it's wrong,
the science must have been sexist or
racist or anything.
Once you're doing that,
you're just,
you're really in the weeds,
you're not helping anybody.
And we need to study areas,
gender and race,
but we need to do it.
Right?
Yeah.
And we need to do it freely where you
could just talk and you don't,
you,
you don't get accused of all sorts of
horrible transgressions.
Exactly.
And that's not,
that's the culture that I,
that we want to see in here.
And that's not the culture we have.
Well I think there's,
you know,
everyone is railing against identity
politics.
I think we can all agree identity
politics are a huge problem,
but another problem that goes along with
it hand in hand is identifying
personally with ideas where these ideas
are connected to your ego identity.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Did you call everybody'S wrong about god
and it sounds like I'm just going to go
after religion,
but it's actually the culmination of my
study of religious psychology and so
really what it was was targeting pr.
I mean it talks about what's going on
with religion and why people believe
religion and what god actually stands
for in terms of psychology as it might
see it,
but then what was really targeting was I
saw all these people who are like,
you know,
loud mouth atheists and they were like
this and that and the other thing and
they have this whole community and I
saw,
holy shit,
they're doing the same thing.
Yes.
They're doing the same thing and what
are they doing?
They're identifying as an atheist,
I am an atheist.
What does that mean?
Well,
I want to be a good atheist.
How the fuck do you be a good atheist?
It doesn't make any sense.
You remember atheism plus atheism plus
was exactly what I was looking at.
Favorite was live,
watched a whole speech like smoking a
joint and laughing my fucking ass off at
this dork who is speaking in front of
some other group of dorks that we're all
part of the atheism plus movement and he
just kept just ranting about sexual
harassment and diversity and all these
different things and attaching them to
atheist.
Exactly.
Motherfucker.
You're making your own religion.
Exactly.
That's exactly right.
Hi.
Joe rogan saw straight through.
It was so fun because the guy was such a
virtue signaling little weasel.
Totally.
It was sneaky fucker.
Yeah,
a little sneaky fucker that was trying
to get girls to like him.
I guarantee you that.
Yo,
you see what it is though.
I got to be a good atheist.
How do I do it?
Well,
I don't know because atheist means don't
believe stuff of a certain kind,
so they have to start plus plus what
social justice.
How did that died off because it didn't
work,
but those people are still grumbling
around or whatever.
BuT what happened?
Oh,
they got a whole blog.
They play about her project.
Yeah.
Said,
yeah,
we're straight white men.
oh,
well you're a straight white man were
therefore we have bad motivations.
Motivations.
That's we get all time because we're
straight white men because bad bad white
men,
straight white men are basically like a
little arrow running around looking for
vaginas and anything you say is
basically just a little sneaky way for
you to get inside of a vagina and all of
this stuff.
You just,
you just try making your way through
society.
It's a little ironic when you Put it
that way,
just what it is.
right?
But the truth is though,
that if they think that the.
I mean this is the article of faith
years that privilege exists and always
preserves itself.
So we're straight white men.
We criticized what supposed to be but
isn't social justice work?
It's bad.
Social justice work,
you know,
capital social justice screwed up.
So we criticize that.
Therefore why we must be,
because we're white man trying
motivation or standard.
Yep.
You guys are a problem.
that was the depth of their analysis,
given that they're,
you know,
like some of them are professors and
stuff that's the best they could come up
with,
been better to say,
you know what,
there's a problem here and we want to
study this stuff and we need to clean
house and thank you guys,
we appreciate it,
but you would have to step so far out of
your belief system and be so objective
and so self aware that you're realizing
you're in some sort of a preposterous
group and very few people are willing to
admit that most of their life's work has
been nonsense.
Yeah.
Especially when you geT rewarded for
that,
you get promoted for that.
you get accolades from that.
You carry status and privilege.
Look at me when people join some fucking
wacky caught like they don't join it
saying,
yeah,
this is bullshit,
but it'll be fun.
They didn't believe it.
They buy into it and this is no
different.
It's like what we're talking about,
about ideologies,
how people they lock into these
predetermined patterns of thinking and
behavior and this is what's happening
here and it's very much like a call.
It's very much like any other group
think sort of environment.
It's like scientology grew up in the
university,
so everything they put out about
threatens and volcanoes or whatever
they've got all of a sudden that's not
like just crazy.
You know,
l ron hubbard,
was it dianetics or whatever.
That's gold standard knowledge.
Academic press,
oxford.
So you get a degree.
yeah.
And then you get to teach it and as
somebody.
Somebody wrote an article criticizing us
history and they're like,
oh,
they don't understand.
You know,
they thInk we just talked to each other
in a bubble.
We talk to policymakers,
we talked to media and it's like,
no shit.
That's why we did this.
You know,
when you talk to you,
you do talk to other people you are
running into,
you know,
per sorry hr departments.
You're telling them how to do the
diversity officers and all those
institutional and talk to policymakers.
I get emails.
I don't know if you saw a year before
all this,
we did this really,
you know,
bad attempt at it called conceptual
penis as a social construct.
So we said that penIses are social
constructs and they cause climate change
and this got a little bit of attention.
I've been getting emails ever since then
from some member of eu parliament and
they're like,
we have another gender initiative that
we're going to try to basically foist
upon you and then it's going to like
dictate how europe now works with africa
going forward about climate.
And so because I wrote this conceptual
penis and climate change thing and it's
all based on,
you know,
making fun of gender studies.
It was at the time anyway,
they were like,
you know,
you're an expert.
So now that you use colomy,
you know,
what do we do about this gender
initiative?
But that's real,
right?
The,
you parliament is not like nothing.
That's not,
that's not,
you know,
it's not like a meeting of some dorks at
a conference that's real.
They're coming up with policy to dictate
how they want to interact with,
with africa for the next 20,
30 years.
That's real.
And these people are emailing me saying
this scholarship that you guys are
criticizing is really,
you know,
it's on the agenda of the eu parliament.
So help.
Alright,
well it seems like what we're,
what we have here is sort of a wave of
ideas,
right?
It goes in and it goes out and it's
going back and forth and you,
you need this sort of balancing act and
there are great things need to go so
haywire that people step in and go,
well I'm pulling my fucking kids at
evergreen state.
Yup.
This is crazy.
It.
That's a great example of a place that
went too far.
Yeah,
and what we don't want to have happen is
we don't want people to pull their kids
out of the universities know because
there are some,
not the university,
but these departments don't major in it.
Exactly.
Don't major in it,
but it's which,
which department?
specific gender studies.
Critical race studies,
cultural studies,
queer theory,
fat studies.
If it happens to have one.
I've read a biography of guy who teaches
critical whiteness.
Oh yeah.
CrItical whiteness is a thing that
actually there was a journal and then it
got.
It got so out there that it got
criticized out of existence,
but it's a big thing.
There's some big paper I was reading
just before we went public with all this
and I got asked about it.
Luckily I read it because we did the
mind calm.
Of course Israel is like,
you got mine comp published.
Oh my god,
we need to talk to you.
Israel tv.
I was on israeli tv.
What the hell?
And so all these israeli journalist or
calling me talking to me about it and
over the mind,
confident I read this one paper.
They're lIke,
well,
do you think that jewish studies is like
this?
And I found this paper just before this
all came out.
There was jewish studies criticizing
critical whiteness studies because
there's this whole thing about how the
critical whiteness people who accused
the jews of being white and then there's
all this,
you know,
who's,
where does the oppression like.
Because you know,
the jews have had it pretty rough over
the last 2000 years or thereabouts,
but then you've got the critical
whiteness people being like,
no,
they're white,
it's a white privilege,
blah,
blah blah.
And then the jewish studies people are
like,
hold up,
you know,
don't put us up here and say that we're
all white supremacists,
you know,
we were gassed by the white
supremacists.
You chill out.
So there's this huge,
like critical studies fight between the
jewish studies people and the critical
whiteness people over whether jews count
as white people are not and have white
supremacy built in.
And they asked me about thIs israeli
journalist said.
And I was like,
well,
you know,
I have to sympathize with what their,
their argument is.
But they're still using the same broken
methods.
And so you still want to see better
Right.
I think the,
the jewish people have a point,
you know,
we've been pretty heavily oppressed for
2000 years.
You sTarted with like,
you know,
the romans decimating them and then the
diaspora and then to holocaust and every
it's just not good.
So I think they have a point that,
you know,
don't just say,
oh,
we have crazy white privilege and are
there for white supremacists,
but if you want to do that,
you know,
maybe this methodology of,
of,
of complaining about it's not the best
way to go.
It's complicated stuff,
but at least they're against the
critical whiteness stuff.
This critical whiteness thing you were
saying is,
is they have a journal.
They did the journal of whiteness
studies or something like that.
Critical whiteness.
It lasted for about three years and I
don't know exactly why it fell apart,
but it fell apart because I was really
upset because I wanted to send a paper
to it and it doesn't exist anymore.
What were you gonna say to the paper on
the rewrite of mind for the woman that
lesbian woman excoriates around
whiteness.
It was going to send it to that journal
and then it doesn't exist anymore.
So I had to send it to a critical race
journal who then said,
ah,
it's a good idea,
but you're positioning yourself as a
good white and that's a problem.
So we can publish.
By the way,
we would.
They're all in line.
We were completely transparent and
honest with everybody.
You can just google drive or google
drive with every paper comments,
comments to everything that mike made,
his videos.
Everything is up there.
Yeah.
It's totally free for everybody.
We get accused of being grifters.
We don't have a how.
How are we grifting?
It's in a google drive that anybody can
just go download all of it.
I don't recall getting money for that.
We want it.
We really do think that that.
And I'm.
Yeah,
there you go.
Swedish professor rebels.
Oh yeah.
A couple of days ago,
one of sweden's most merited in claim
political scientists and longterm
critics of identity politics.
Bow rothstein.
Rothstein has argued that identity based
disciplines like grievance studies,
which deals with the concept of
collective guilt,
have no place in academia.
Yeah.
Grievance studies is.
Yeah,
right on.
we,
we came up with greed and study,
so delighted to see that that's caught
on to start a podcast immediately and a
patrion page so that you don't have to
worry about losing your house.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
I don't know how it is in Sweden.
Yeah,
I don't either,
but that guy's probably screwed.
Whatever the fuck they did with Jordan
Peterson,
they created a god damn monster.
Oh yeah.
You guys fucked up.
Guys created a multimillionaire whose
worldwide famous and there's a huge
bestseller and he was just talking to
swedish politicians on tv the other day,
so watch out.
They fucked up with him.
Boy,
did they fuck up and dave was just
texting me.
A friend.
Reuben was just texting me pictures that
all full.
It's crazy in the energy in that place
is crazy.
He's selling out 5,000
seat theaters.
He's a rock star.
It's a fucking rock star.
He's an intellectual rockstar.
It's hilarious.
Good for him.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
a lot of other guys are doing it to sam
harris is doing that as well.
They're doing these gigantic huge
speeches.
It's like good for him.
What will absolutely good for him,
but what I'm excited about is how many
people are interested in the debate of
ideas and that this is not happening on
the college campuses,
but a lot of these people that are
graduated have graduated from college or
or you know,
in the working world.
They're very fascinated by this.
It's real.
It's what you were saying.
It's been suppressed for long enough
now.
Jordan peterson,
what was his thing?
He was like,
you're not going to tell me the words I
can use when they're 78 different words
for genders.
I can safely say you're fucking crazy.
That's like this desperation to try to
find a unique identity that you can
consider it to be super special or
whatever.
It's totally,
but it's.
And you want to see even crazier as you
go into,
like you go on these blogs.
I Think they're mostly on tumblr or
something that violates my rule.
never use tumbler where they talk about
the different sexual sexuality
identities,
like different kinds of,
you know,
I'm interested in this kind of personal
but not this kind of person under these
circumstances but not under those that
has like some 18 syllable academic word
for it now and there's people whose
whole,
I don't think their academics.
I think there are activists geeks on
tumbler,
but they come up with these crazy
descriptions and there's like hundreds
of sexual orientations.
Yeah.
It's just people wanting to be
different.
I think it'd be special and they're not
good at anything.
That's I think something that was the
other part of.
I guess one of the things that jim said
when I said I was more cynical,
I think that the in general,
the critics tend to be angry and I'm not
saying that their anger is legitimate or
illegitimate,
but they send to be angry.
They seem to be almost universally under
accomplished,
so they're upset at you because you have
whatever,
a big show or lot of fault or they're
whatever.
They're upset about big platform
audience there.
They're just generally disagreeable
people and they found these communities
of other people who are enraged,
who are also under accomplished,
who they can laugh,
they can lash out at people together,
and then virtue signal you get rewarded
for all know rogan that bat whatever
they want to call you or whatever they
want to call us or whoever else,
some kind of an oppressor,
some pressure,
and that there's something that.
So I don't know how we can deal with
that.
I mean was our attempt to do this was to
try to de legitimize where they get
their knowledge from,
like what they call knowledge,
what they could point to.
We tried to say it's not knowledge and
de-legitimizing,
but we really do need to get back to
some kind of productive discussion,
productive politics where the far right
disown they're lunatics and we disown
are lunatics and we get back to work
about whatever the oceans,
plastic,
whatever it is that we're talking about,
because right now the discourse is
corrupted it.
We're not doing what we need to do in
the.
These people
are continuing to pump out this
nonsense.
that's totally untethered reality.
It's a huge problem.
I'm sick of it.
You're sick of it.
We're all sick and we're sick of.
I'm sick of it.
I've had it.
I've had it with these folks.
It just doesn't seem.
It doesn't seem like it's sustainable.
I don't think it is.
It seems like some weird thing that's
going to run out of energy towards
eating itself constantly eats itself
like we did.
The thing about the the people of color
and the black indigenous people of color
that they fragmented.
You see when you get into the critical
race literature that it's like,
okay,
so you're brown or black,
but you have slightly lighter skin,
slightly darker skin is slightly darker
than that.
Really dark.
They have different levels of privilege
and it's just cutting things apart.
The idea though that this is going to
create some kind of a coalition that can
then defeat the plurality or something
like that is ridiculous.
So what do you see?
You see this stuff starting to blow up.
You see the democrats bleed seats.
They've lost lIke a thousand legislative
seats across the u.
S since obama got elected in [inaudible]
eight.
How are you going to get your agenda if
you don't have any legislators,
if you don't have anybody elected,
and so then what happens?
Two thousand 16.
I don't.
I can't say that the reason that trump
got elected because there's lots of
reasons it had something to do.
No,
I will say I had something to do with
this because every conservative person I
know that's not just a reactionary is
like.
And I live in the soUtheast man.
I,
I know some conservatives,
most of my friends who are
conservatives,
because I don't have a choice if I want
to have friends that they're going to be
conservatives who lives there.
So I talked to them and they're like,
oh yeah,
they're tearing down this statue.
Oh yeah.
It's tough.
And it's not like they're tearing down
confederate statues are turning on
Thomas Jefferson,
you know,
it's like there.
George Washington,
George Washington halloween's a problem.
Then I didn't know.
You didn't know how it means a problem.
What are you going as for halloween?
I'm a shark.
You're a sharp.
My kids are mermaids.
Problematic.
Oh god.
If they're mermaids and you're a shark,
you're definitely taking like a dominant
power position.
Power.
They.
I don't pick my off that I have kids.
They tell me what I am.
Not an issue,
but I don't know.
I'll try to figure out a paper for that.
Halloween.
Halloween?
Yes.
Oh god.
Cultural appropriation.
Why apologizes for tropic thunder?
Simple jack costume.
Oh no.
He dressed up as a black person.
You know?
Simple.
Jack is the mentally handicapped.
Okay.
That's all right.
It's junior.
Might be the last guy ever to wear black
face.
Yeah,
that's true.
Pull it off.
What are they?
Gonna.
Pull that.
That show.
What are they goIng to pull?
Tropic thunder is problematic.
I don't even.
There's probably a tropic thunder.
It's wonderful.
You'll love it and it's.
It's special.
Highly politically incorrect.
It's politically and writing it down.
Tropic thunder is.
It is a fucking great move is a gem.
It's a great movie.
Now we're going to be racists and
abelist for saying that.
It's funny for short.
We've got real issues.
We do halloween again.
Halloween is mostly,
It's.
There's a lot of cultural appropriation
going on,
so somebody might dress up like a put on
a sombrero and a poncho.
That's an issue,
especially on tuesdays.
We have tacos today.
You know,
you can't be a native american,
you can't be a native american.
There's that big stink just now about
the victoria's secret fashion show where
they had like their indigenous,
you know,
colors and the feathers they were
wearing and walking around half naked.
You can't do that.
So the idea mostly that people are going
to take costumes that are insensitive to
other people's cultural appropriation,
cultural appropriation.
So it's not dress up as Bruce Lee.
Oh man.
I don't know.
MaYbe for awhile for a harvard,
maybe because he's asian and then it
gets complicated,
but no,
this all blew up at yale a few years ago
I thought for sure.
He's.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
How do you spell hIs last name?
christakis I think christakis.
Yeah,
sometime soon.
he's supposed to.
He's a good guy.
Um,
yeah.
That was hilarious.
It was kids screaming at screaming at
him.
Safe place.
Yup.
It was just his wife
put out a email saying maybe it's okay
to believe politically incorrect on
halloween.
It was.
Yeah.
It was just,
you know,
choose your costume,
how you're going to choose it.
We're all adults.
It's probably bad to be deliberately
offensive and yet it's also bad to
overreact to incidental stuff.
Oh yeah.
It's all this stuff.
You kNow,
like little girls if are white can dress
up as milan.
oh,
that's right.
Behind us or about pocahontas is a new
one.
Yeah,
pocahontas problem.
But I think Bruce Lee is still on the
menu.
I don't think anybody's getting in
trouble for being Bruce Lee.
You could wear it like the track suit
where I get the treks didn't.
That's a big footprint across my chest,
right footprint.
We our cream of kicked in,
but a lot of people go with the.
Like the cutS.
oh yeah.
The.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't have enough apps for that.
That's going to be a bad costume for
what is it is.
Yeah.
You could buy a Bruce Lee costume.
Look for now,
for now,
for now.
Who knows?
it comes with a weight to dope for now,
even a baby costume.
Look at that.
Obviously chinese babies,
chinese.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That guy's fucking guy.
No,
no,
not allowed.
Can't be a ninja.
No way to cultural appropriation.
a boy this,
this mess that we're in.
Is there a light at the end of the
tunnel?
Nothing.
So.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think so.
Uh,
the response that we've got so far has
been really positive,
but it's all like the secret positive.
So the feeling I get is academia.
Well from academics.
Yeah.
the general public has been way more
positive than that.
PosItive for positive.
So the wind is changing,
right?
If we're getting that much,
we've got no real blow back.
We got,
we got lots of posItivity from the
public.
Even academics are reaching out there
like secret positive with them.
It's like one more thing,
right?
We need a critical mass because what
they are is they're all lined up.
They know the first one to step out of
line and challenged the stuff's getting
shot.
So like the communist situation,
after communism fell,
nobody really believed it anymore.
But they had to go along with the party
are going to get shot,
but if a whole bunch of people come
forward at once,
they can shoot everybody.
So if feels like we're in that powder
keg situation now,
right where all it's going to take is we
hoped it was going to be this,
you know,
our,
our thing was going to be the trigger
that like 30 percent of academics come
forward and say,
you know,
it's bullshit and if enough people start
saying it,
other people start feeling safe to say
it and we wish them where people feel
safe,
you know,
we took a risk,
it's been fine for us and we'll see what
happens to pete.
But if more people will take that risk
and start speaking out,
then there's change coming.
Now.
You were,
you were a mathematician and that's your
background.
And in academia that would appear at
least to be something that is beyond all
this stuff because it's just dealing
with numbers.
Yeah.
Math itself mostly has not been touched
by this,
but there's this whole branch in there
that's called the studies of science and
technology.
And mostly what they go after is,
you know,
the sciences or whatever,
especially they go after,
um,
biology and psychology and they feel
like they've got a lot of inroads into
that.
We wroTe the astronomy paper to try to
push that all the way to a hard science.
We've said that astronomy is sexist and
can only be fixed by putting in queer
horoscopes.
they thought that was a good project.
They keep asking them to rewrite it.
Yeah.
They keep asking me to submit that.
I got an email yesterday asking for that
one again.
So even though we've come public.
So with math mostly where you see this
stuff hitting though,
they don't.
I mean some people are saying that math
is inherently got sexism and racism
because I guess apparently women and
minorities are going to be naturally bad
at numbers is what they're assuming.
I don't know what they're assuming does
it,
that's ludicrous.
But they mostly go after educatIon.
So they say,
oh look,
the scores on the sat math scores or
whatever For,
for men,
white men are higher than for,
for black men or something like that.
Why could that be?
Well,
you know,
maybe there are a lot of factors that go
into that,
but they Don't give a shit about a lot
of factors.
it's racism,
so therefore math education must be
racist.
Therefore we need social justice
initiatives in math education and that's
exactLy what they do.
And so then you have diversity math and
I don't know even know what that is,
but it's not something that you would
see like at mathematics research level,
it's something that you see at junior
high school,
elementary school that they're teaching
your kids,
which is why it's scary as hell.
So is there a light at the end of the
tunnel and what do you still think?
There's a lot.
I think people hate this stuff.
I think people are getting sick.
I hate it.
Hate it.
Hate it too though.
But they're afraid.
Yeah.
I had this guy come up to me repeatedly
last week.
This guy,
he's got two phd,
brilliant guy.
He comes up to me repeatedly.
What you did is so important.
It's so necessary.
I can't talk about it.
I'm sorry.
I wish I could talk about it,
but I talked to a lot of academics and
everybody's saying the same thing.
They know you got them.
It's only a matter of time now.
One more event and theY shake off the
fear.
I think it's close.
I don't knoW what the next event is.
I don't think it's more bogus papers.
I think it's probably somebody's getting
fired that didn't deserve it or
something like that.
One more thing and people are going to
be ready to shake this off it.
Why does this ideology,
in fact,
tech companies and it seems to get them
more than it gets anyone else.
We should ask them more that I don't
know.
He's.
He's fucked.
If I can't get a job.
He just gone.
I just to him the other day,
he just gone,
well,
don't say where he's working.
Oh,
definitely.
They'll go after him.
Yeah.
No,
why?
It's in tech so much.
Maybe there's some kind of silicon
valley connection there or whatever
where you know silicon valley is in,
you know the kind of bay area,
California.
You've got a lot of the liberal hippie
stuff that started out as you were
talking about in the sixties and
seventies,
so it's kind of in the water there in
general.
I would say that what you're seeing is
that this stuff,
as they've got the big turn to making
this applied was in the nineties.
Right?
So they've had an entire generation of
students that have just been really
getting this stuff crammed down their
throat.
They really have taken over the
education in the last 10 years.
It was just starting when I left
academia in 2010 that,
you know,
it was like,
oh,
we're going to focus on diversity.
We're in a diversity committee,
commitments,
what's going to get into general
curriculum.
So you're getting more and more students
that are getting educated in this,
that is now going out into the
workplace.
Right.
So if half your workforce in tech,
Because tech moves so fast,
I'm just guessing why this might be a
thing.
Tech was really fast,
so you've got to have some fresh
training go in there.
If they've been educated with diversity,
stuff's crammed down their throat the
whole time and there's huge initiatives
to try to,
you know,
increase representation of women in
particular in,
in tech and these are seen as,
you know,
automatically good initiatives.
If there has been,
this is the culture that they're,
that they're being educated in,
and then they take that culture to the
workplace and think this is what tech is
about,
and then they're surrounded by
likeminded people who encourage it.
It's totally plausible that which you've
got to sort of a tech echo chamber
that's bouncing these things around and
keeping it,
keeping it there.
Here's another question.
Why is it that,
I mean,
here's,
here's the scenario,
right?
The scenario is universities are almost
predominantly taught by people that are
on the left.
It's massive.
It's in the 90 percent range,
right?
when you have this sort of environment
of these nonsense ideas that are
accepted as fact and taught and put into
published papers,
then you have a situation where the left
routinely attacks itself and and,
and devours Itself for not being left
enough.
You're always having people that are
upset that someone's not progressive
enough,
leftwing people attacking leftwing
people.
You do not see that on the right.
No,
you did.
That's kind of what the whole tea party
movement was.
Right,
but they didn't do it in the academic
field because they didn't power there
because they weren't academics.
right?
Well,
yeah.
That shift started in the sixties and
seventies.
They started bringing in these field
when that was during the obama
administration,
so that's when.
What was the biggest fear for every
republican congressman then was that
they're going to get primaried from the
right,
so they were going to have some
populist.
Yahoo goes screaming about whatever they
scream about.
It was going to be more to the right,
harder conservatism,
conservative movement,
capital c,
capital m kind of thing,
and they're going to just drill into
the,
you know,
the reason that,
that the conservative politics aren't
succeeding is because we're not
conservative enough,
is that's the,
the prevailing view where I live in the
southeast.
so same thing as you see in the
universities,
but reversed in terms of,
of polarization.
So,
but isn't thAt just an excuse for the
lack of success?
It is.
It's,
it's a,
it's within excuse combined with a
commitment to the ideology,
whether it's conservative movement
ideology,
whether it's a social justice
scholarship,
whatever it happens to be.
Right.
But you see far more of these left on
left attacks they need do write on right
attacks you do right now.
Yeah,
certainly.
Except of course for election time,
certain people were trying to beat their
opponents.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
It just,
it seems to be that there's somehow or
another related.
I mean I would like to look at how many
people on the left will attack others
for not being progressive enough,
not being left enough.
So I think it's a panic,
rIght?
You see this is the kind of behavior you
see in a panic,
a moral panic,
for example.
And so helen and I,
the third person who worked on the
project with us,
helen and I wrote an essay about a year
and a half ago and talking about how the
extremism on both sides is really the
problem and most people reject it and
should fight it.
Most of us are sensible people in the
middle who hate this.
In fact,
data just came out showing that it's 80
percent of the population,
the fringes,
both sIdes.
So n only eight percent are on the left
and 12 percent are on the right of the
fringe.
However that works out.
And so we wrote this thing and we said,
what's going on?
Actually we called it existential
polarization.
So you have this idea that everything's
an existential crisis.
So the the far right,
we'll start with them,
sees that if the democrats get power,
oh,
it's open borders.
The terrorists are coming in.
Our entire way of life is going to be
destroyed.
Catastrophe,
catastrophe,
ono,
judith butler's,
you mean 95 genders?
Quick stop the democrats no matter what.
And then you have the left.
Oh my god,
if they get power that everything's
going to be racist,
we're going to be beating gays in the
snow.
It's going to just be the worst thing.
That's actually kind of a joke,
but,
but it's,
it's for real though,
that they think that the world is going
to fall apart.
If the other side it gets power and so
when you have that kind of a situation,
you have a panic and you see the
slightest bit of advantage happening on
the other side is just something to
completely freak out about.
And then what do you do?
You say,
oh well the only possible recipe to
balance the scales to turn further our
way.
If we go toward the middle,
that puts the balance.
SaY if the right goes really far right
and we on the left,
moved toward the middle.
Now the whole balance has moved,
right?
So the only way to keep the balance
close to the middle is if they go right,
we go left,
right?
Right.
So then that's going to keep the
balance.
But what that actually does is it.
This is going to get nerdy.
Hang on.
That actually puts all of the weight on
the outsides and you think about a
spinning thing,
right?
It's got centrifugal forces happening.
What's that trying to do is going to rip
the spinning thing apart?
Well,
if you have all the weight crammed in
the middle,
like wheel,
it doesn't come apart right now.
imagine if you had like two billiard
balls and you have like this big long
stick and there's two holes for the
builder bars.
They don't go in it like locked in
there,
just sitting there.
You spend that.
What's going to happen there?
Fly right off,
right?
So if you have all the weight on the
outside and you start spinning a thing,
so that's like the political
conversations.
That dynamic is going to rip the thing
apart.
The more weight gets to the outside.
So one side go into the fringe doesn't
mean the other side should go to the
fringe.
That's how you tear a nation apart.
That actually makes a lot of sense.
If you can conceptualize it like an
object.
There's really a damn good youtube video
floating around out there where somebody
takes a jet of water in,
spins a skateboard wheel until the
centrifical force gets so high from it
spending so fast,
it rips it apart.
It's it's worth looking up.
I don't know what the hell you'd search
to find it,
but it's a powerful visual and you can
see it as stuff moves to the outside.
The centrifical force goes up and up and
up until finally the thing that the
structural integrity of the thing that's
spinning can't hold itself together.
Anyone it rips apart.
Well,
listen gentlemen and a shout out to your
friend.
What is her name?
Nine.
Uh,
oh,
helen.
Helen.
Oh,
Helen Rose.
Rose across the pond.
Um,
thank you guys for doing this.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks for being here,
man.
I appreciate your support because we
need support.
We can't do this without support,
so thanks for having us.
My pleasure.
Thanks for doing it.
Where can people see these things?
Where can they read them?
The best place to go is going to be to
go to our film makers youtube page,
mike naina on the youtube that just a n
a n a y and a and a y and so on.
His youtube pages,
some videos.
He's kind of playing with the footage
that he's collecting for the
documentary.
On top of that though,
if you go to the video we originally
released,
which is on the page,
you can find it easily.
There's the link to the google drive is
linked to all of the documents we put
out winters.
We explained what every paper does,
why we wrote it,
what we were trying to show with writing
the papers,
what the problem is that we need to
address and what you know,
what we think that this shows and what
we can do.
It's all accessible through his youtube
channel.
We're kind of making that a central hub
and so people can go there and explore
and watch some more videos of us and
we'll.
Thanks for beIng here.
This was a lot of fun.
Again,
I really appreciate what you guys do and
thanks man.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.